oh
e
good afternoon welcome to house finance
committee for May 15 May
14th um like to note that we have some
replacements for members who are not
present we have representative Lane
replacing representative huitt
representative Shapiro representing uh
representative muray and representative
groa representing replacing
representative Lehman
and we have one bill that we didn't
complete in yesterday's calendar
453 making appropriation to the
Statewide voter registration system
recognize representative
Maguire thank you Mr chair so as you
recall this is um just a a simple bill
to pay for this um uh voter registration
portal and um the problem we ran into
yesterday was that the uh that the
committee in the senate for some crazy
reason that I don't you know it's like
above my pay grade um the bill there's a
house bill that has all the policy to
create the portal and how it's to be
done and so on but there's this Senate
bill to pay for it why it can't be in
one bill is unknown but anyways so but
it wouldn't make sense so that Bill the
house bill in the Senate is currently uh
recommended for interim study so that's
the problem we don't really want to
spend
$450,000 and I spoke to Assistant
Attorney J assistant Secretary of State
Hennessy who says the money is
specifically for that so if they don't
have the house bill they can't have they
can't spend this money and so on um so
what this does what this amendment does
and I'm talking about Amendment 1926 H
which I am moving um is to change the
dollar amount to a dollar and therefore
should the Senate decide to change their
mind from interim study and go back to
um ought to pass then they could ask for
a committee of conference on this we
could change it back to
$450,000 and everybody would be happy I
guess um I'll second his move thank you
and uh
um now it seems to me there actually is
an alternative which is the Senate could
amend the house bill to add the
$450,000 and then it would be all in one
bill Etc but for some reason people
don't seem to want that or I don't know
what but anyways that's this
amendment can we adopt the
representative able yes thank you Mr
chair I um uh understand what
representative Maguire is trying to
accomplish with this but since the
Senate hasn't actually voted and there's
only a recommend recommendation on the
floor from the committee and it's a
three to2 recommendation at that um I
will be uh opposing the amendment thank
you thank you further discussion on the
amendment which is 1
1926 if there is no further discussion
all in favor of adopting the amendment
opposed okay I come up 12 to 12 because
we got one member Miss
dies all right we we got representative
Sweeny Mr chairman I would move interim
study on Senate Bill
okay we we'll have uh representative
papichi Muller back shortly he said he
just needed five minutes so S swe no
papa yeah representative Sweeney moves
interim study is there a second second
by
Maguire further
discussion representative tki I just
want to reiterate what representative
eel said um we don't even know how the
Senate's going to act on this I say we
go ahead we take the division one
recommendation of ought to pass we pass
it and we work it out in Committee of
conference if if there's something to be
done we'll work it out I don't
understand why we are going to kill a
bill that we the division unanimously
thought was a good idea so I'll be
voting against interim study thank you
Mr
chair all right representative Abel and
then I'll come to representative hle
yeah just uh circling back once again I
would just reiterate the fact that this
came out with a unanimous recommendation
from The Division I also went back and
looked at the uh house floor vote it was
a unanimous Voice vote um I don't see
why just because the Senate May interim
study this that we should be wiping out
the bill so I'll be voting against the
result representa hle yes thank you Mr
chair um in that this bill is verbatim
with what the Senate passed if we pass
this bill it heads to the governor it
does not go back to the Senate
procedurally so if we want to do
anything about a committee of conference
for the purpose of discussion we need to
do something it can be any amendment of
any type but otherwise procedurally it
does not return to the Senate it goes to
the
governor thank
you all right so the uh motion I have we
haven't disposed of yet is inim study by
representative Sweeney seconded by
representative Maguire does everyone
know the situation is clear interim
study is the motion before us on Senate
Bill 453 Is there further
discussion seeing none representative
Griffin you have got your light on
okay any further discussion seeing none
the clerk will call a rooll on the
motion of interim study on Senate Bill
453 thank you Mr chairman representative
F yes representative Maguire yes
representative Petri votes yes
representative Emer yes representative
Griffin yes representative Mooney yes
representative Edwards
yes representative Bean yes
representative hle
yes representative Sweeney yes
representative camell yes represent
papichi Muller yes Representative walner
no representative Grody no
Representative buo no representative
Lane
no representative Heath no
representative
Shapiro no
representative eel
no Representative torki no
yes
sorry n no I'm just trying to give you
an example of what what it sounds like n
no no a good a good s on there and a
good no okay okay I take that as a no we
only going to be allowed one vote from
now on want get it right representa
Stringham k n o w
no that's
confusing representative
grass
no representative Priest
No represent wer yes Mr chairman the
vote is 13 to 12 in favor of the motion
and it'll be a new blur there will be a
Minority Report minority yeah Minority
Report who will be the minority
represent repres AEL thank you he okay
all right and what was what's the motion
interim study oh what what's what's your
report on your
minority be recommending ought to pass
okay very good okay I assume that but to
make sure you never know that's that's
why we have to ask all right we mov on
next on our schedule is Senate Bill
217 call on representative emmer thank
you Mr chairman I would uh recognize
representative Hain Phillips for a
motion thank you Mr chair I move ought
to pass on Senate Bill
2117 and I'm happy to speak to my motion
time okay motion of second for ought to
pass on Senate Bill 217 further
discussion
representative maen Phillips thank you
Mr chair so um division 2 heard um
Senate Bill 217 in committee and um
largely heard from um one um lobbyist
who was really trying to deliver the
deliberations he had witnessed uh in the
other body um it's important to know
that this house bill uh I'm sorry the
Senate bill when it came to the house
looked slightly different um
the um it is not a loan repayment
program for uh Rural and underserved
area Educators
um um instead it's more of a retention
payment over time to keep Target um
target areas of Rural and underserved
areas in public schools those teachers
committed to the work that they're doing
over time uh the primary intent of the
bill was to exp um was to support these
teachers
uh as we all know their U professional
educational expenses are um
exponentially increasing and it gets
harder to keep them retaining the jobs
over time if they're not um addressing
kind of their
long-term um repayment programs um so
the funding is intended um to to keep
them where they are uh this in fact
would be a future budget um increase for
an appropriation and another time um
although the values as you can see on
page two of the original bill that total
incentive program does increase over
time I think the total was about
$112,000 um but it's like a four-year
retention
program but it is not appropriated um
it's only a dollar appropriation
included in the bill so this is really a
in in like aspirational program for
future
budgeting uh as such the felt it was
important to retain those rural um
teachers where they are and noted that
this is also similar to a healthcare
provider program that the state supports
so um we felt um I guess a six to2 vote
we felt it was important as it ought to
pass thank you further discussion on
Senate Bill
217 representative Emer thank you Mr
chairman uh in committee I I say I
agreed with intent of this bill it had
no the cost was $1 so it was not an
expensive Bill however it did obligate
future uh legislature to fund
it since we had this committee meeting
uh the amount of liability we have for
the senu center has grown exponentially
so I'm very reluctant to commit a
program for a future legislature when
we're going to be handing off a a huge
liability on the news center so I cannot
support the bill at this
time further
discussion representative Heath um I I'd
just like to talk a little bit about
those school districts in our most rural
areas and the difficulty that they have
attracting teachers this would be an
incentive that would encourage our young
new teachers going to places that they
wouldn't that they might not other wise
go um and actually Esa um our title
$1 often provide these incentives so it
may be something that the Department of
Education could use some federal dollars
for I don't know the answer to that but
I think we need to think seriously about
those school districts that is very
difficult right now there are school
districts that are using vac as the
means by which they teach AP courses um
advanced science courses math courses
and it would be so much better if they
could attract teachers to those areas
thank you very much and I hope you'll
consider the OTP
motion further
discussion representa Hull thank you Mr
chair um currently there's no Financial
note on this or even an estimate other
than the
$1 the the modified bill as passed by
the house is roughly $112,000 per
applicant of reimbursement grants
um not understanding the number of
teachers that's eligible if we if we
actually you if actually every one of
the approximately 15,000 teachers was
eligible we're talking over $100 million
and I don't know how many teachers would
be eligible to to move to these new
areas do we have any information for
that does anyone know the answer I don't
have an exact figure but the number of
teachers in our rural school districts
is I I would say in the low numbers
depending and in particular subject
areas so um I would not say they would
be I'm not sure I can't give you an
exact
number represent hacken Philip Mr some
of the testimony that division 2 heard
um was about teacher teaching
eligibility in these areas um and we do
we were reminded that there were um some
alternative Pathways to teaching in our
state through an all three or alt four
track which uh would basically be people
who are not certified teachers and our
traditional understanding of who becomes
a teacher but instead those who have a
college degree or credit hours in a
certain teaching um educational area and
have experience in the field who can um
either become a teacher or a pair
professional through these additional
Pathways this provides um you know it's
really getting at the teacher um
shortage that we're seeing across the
state and provides an alternative
pathway for folks to get into the
profession this program is meant to also
be available to those folks so we're not
talking about um The Limited um teachers
in the rural area of our state but also
you know trying to draw some of the
experts from our areas who might be
willing you know in a second career to
come and serve in our schools so um you
know there was not data analysis
provided but I can tell you it's not
15,000 teachers who are eligible for
this rural targeted um incentive program
thank you and we're losing about 3% of
the students every year so you would
think that the losses would be keeping
up with the teachers anyway further
discussion represent hold you have your
light on did you want to say
anything there's no further discussion
the clerk will call a role on the motion
of ought to pass on Senate Bill 217
thank you Mr chairman representative
Earth
no representative McGuire no
representative Petri votes no
representative em
no representative Griffin
no representative Mooney
no representative Edwards no
representative Bean no Representative
hle no representative Sweeney no
Representative camell no represent
Popovich Muller
no representative walner yes representa
Grody
yes representative buo yes
representative Lane yes representative
Heath yes representative Shapiro
yes representative eel yes
representative toori yes representative
Hawkin Phillips yes representative
Stringham yes repres res
grassy yes representative priest yes
representative wer no Mr chairman the
vote is
defeated is there an alternate motion Mr
chairman I move
itl is there a
second
second second by representative Sweeney
motion before us is itl for Senate Bill
217 Is there further
discussion seeing none the clerk will
call the role on the motion of
inexpedient to
legislate for Senate Bill 2117 who made
Sweeney good thank you Mr chairman
representative F
yes represent McGuire yes represent
Peter vot
yes representative emmer
yes representative Griffin yes
representative Mooney yes representative
Edwards yes representative Bean yes
representative hle yes representative
Sweeny yes representative camell yes
representative Pichi Muller yes
Representative walner no representative
uh
no representative Heath
no representative evil no represent
torski no repres pres of haen Phillips
no very good representative
Stringham no representative grassy no
representative
Priest No representative uh wer
yes Mr chair the vote is 13- 12 in favor
of the motion we have adopted
inexpedient to legislate for Senate Bill
217 I'll write the report thank thank
you and Mr chair I'll write The Minority
you representative Amer is recognized
for Senate Bill 362 thank you Mr chair
recogniz I recognized representative po
pich
Mo thank you Mr chair um just to make a
long story short ASB 362 is a bill that
requires um a study to be completed
about uh know the potential concerns
around body warn cameras by Public
Safety it does not have any U new
Appropriations attached since the
request can be fulfilled from the
existing funds and therefore uh there
shouldn't be a need to talk about it any
further I would make a motion to
OTP motion of about to pass on Senate
Bill 362 who's the
second representative Petri
representative Petri oh all right
further discussion
seeing
none when you're ready the clerk will
call the role for the motion of ought to
pass on Senate Bill
362 thank you Mr chairman representative
F yes representative guire yes
representative Petri votes yes
representative Emer yes representative
Griffin yes representative Mooney yes
representative Edwards yes
representative Bean yes representative
hle yes representative Sweeney yes
represent camell yes represent papichi
meller yes represent waler yes
representative gery
yes representative buo yes
representative Lane yes representative
Heath yes representative Shapiro yes
representative eel yes represent torki
yes represent haen Phillips yes
representative Stringham yes
representative grass yes representative
priest yes and representative wer
yes Mr chairman the vote is 25 to Z in
favor of the
motion the motion about to pass was
adopted for Senate Bill
362 representative
emmer Mr chairman I think 362 could go
on
consent which one the one we just voted
has no money in it 362 362 on consent
yes and represent papovich Miller will
write the report thank you
yeah on Senate Bill 396 do we have I I
believe Mr chairman there's an amendment
on this
one funding
amendment oh yes oh there the there is
an amendment because this was one of the
ones that when I went to the arpa
discussion the funding had been added to
excess arpa
funds um for the ventilation and exhaust
fans in New Hampshire culinary arts
teaching kits at William Palmer CTE
Senator and Hudson
so last I looked
um Kevin Ripple had had the
Amendments is is
he if you give me one moment I can print
we we were asked to draft this but
nobody indicated it was going for you
show me a stack of these ones that we
had from these ARA funds I I can print
it if you just give me a few minutes
here all right in the meantime I think
representative Heath was very happy now
that it's
bill do we need to wait for the
amendment um it's just a source of
funding that we're um looking for all
prepared with that Amendment today I do
have the department here to verify that
if you want hear find out cuz Kevin
showed me a pile of amendments he had
so anyone here that can give us an
opinion on that
hiding think I think there are other
bills with arpa amendments and this one
was discussed however I think this use
was deemed not something permissible for
those funds which is why I wasn't
prepared with that Amendment for you
today but we can is anyone here that can
discuss it and please identify
yourself good afternoon Melissa white
division director for learner support at
the New Hampshire Department of
Education um this uh particular project
would not qualify for the arpa funds
because of all the federal requirements
needed for construction this has already
happened in the past we can't go back
and come into compliance with the
federal requirements in the past so that
it would not
qualify that's right does have have a a
deadline for construction I think the
other two ones that are down here for
arpa funds do not have construction
involved so they won't be correct
overridden all right well just moved
from arpa funds to General funds so then
then the motion before us is ought to
pass yes I believe it's from the
education trust fund yes the education
trust funds okay can I speak to the
that's representative Heath is
recognized so I would like to move ought
to pass on Senate Bill 396
second and if I could speak to my
motion um Senator Carson um brought this
bill to us um the um Wilbur Palmer
Regional Career and Technical education
center was qualified for a grant I
believe through the capital budget and
there was a miscommunication between the
department and the center
um and they went ahead believing that
they had been approved to do um a an
adjustment and use the additional funds
that they had so I would ask that we um
pass this bill and and take the funds
that that are necessary from the
education trust fund to make the um
School District hold it was um a
miscommunication and um I spoke with
Senator Carson last night and she's
hopeful that we will pay attention to
this bill and pass
it thank you further discussion seeing
none are you ready for the question
clerk will call the role on the motion
of ought to pass on Senate Bill
396 thank you Mr chairman representative
er
no representative Maguire
no representative Petri votes yes
representative amri
no
yes representative Edwards
yes representative Bean
yes Representative
hle
no representative Sweeny
yes representative camell yes
representative PU Muller yes
representative walner yes representative
groy yes representative buo yes
representative Lane yes representative
Heath yes representative I didn't hear
yes represent representative Shapiro
yes representative evil yes
representative torki yes representative
haen Phillips yes
yes representative Stringham yes
representative grassy yes representative
priest yes and representative Wier
yes Mr chair the vote is 21 to4 in favor
of the
motion motion 21 to4 we have adopted
ought to pass is it going to be a
Minority
Report you're writing the majority
report will there be a Minority Report
from those who voted no okay none none
is
reported
yes I just said the money
67 all
right representative Emer is recognized
for Senate Bill
352 oh wait a minute getting ahead of
myself yeah Senate Bill 311 this one I
do have an
amendment doesn't involve construction
so as I said before I attended an arpa
meeting on April 30th the only members
of the House were myself and the speaker
and I saw that uh the senate had put
Senate Bill 311 as one of the bills that
they wanted to fund with excess arpa
meeting so the mo the amendment you see
before
all right I move the
amendment is there a
second
it so this is only for this current year
this will be I think the third year that
the town has received property tax
abatement U that was an important item I
did
represent Hamad when all this was
ongoing um the town was not in favor of
it this was to elay some of their
complaints
about adopting
this Hospital in their town and they of
course I think expect it to continue but
for this year this is the one-time
payment that will be approved for this
year
and we adopt the amendment by a show of
hand hands down any
opposition didn't think they any so the
adopted I would now move
not to pass second on Senate Bill 311
okay further
discussion representative Stringham
Senate Bill 311 provides a one town
onetime payment to the town of Hamstead
for $191,000
uh in fiscal year 2025 to offset the
impact of the town's uh property tax
base uh resulting from the state's
acquisition of the Hemstead Hospital
Hemstead hospital is an accredited
Specialty Hospital that serves acute
psychiatric and substance abuse abuse
disorders uh for the needs of children's
adolescents and young adults as a
state-owned facility the state does not
pay property tax and therefore payment
in Le in Le of tax taxes or a pilot is
used on occasion uh in New Hampshire to
offset lost revenues or to offset added
costs uh this payment was anticipated in
last year's hb2 but uh reportedly was
inadvertently excluded in the Senate
version of the bill uh as amended this
payment would largely come from federal
funds or arpa funds uh so uh I move uh
support a to pass very good and you're
writing the report and it's already
written is there a
second I'll second
it it was already seconded it's already
seconded okay all right motion is ought
to pass as amended and the amendment is
before you
1867 representative Maguire thank you Mr
chairman so I I caught the the phrase uh
on occasion that we do this and I'm
wondering is there any kind of
principal reason why we do it in this
case and not some other case and so on I
mean I've never heard of one I have
Connecticut River
Valley I don't mean that I haven't heard
of payments being made I haven't heard
of a reason why we do it here and not
there do you see what I mean because
there were I could certainly come up
with cases where we don't make some kind
of payment like
this it's always up to the legislature M
Mr chair can I may I offer
representative Edwards uh I don't I
don't think this is
um describes a principle as much as a a
real situation you know with Hamstead
they had a longstanding uh history with
the private ownership of the Hamstead
hospital and when the state bought it
the Hamstead lost a significant amount
of of um uh real uh property taxes and
and uh when we went in there as a State
we increased the level of Acuity the of
the patients that would be seen there
and we have had a series of uh
disruptions relative
to what had happened prior to our
takeover that has brought into bear fire
EMT police and so uh so we've taken
their property tax revenue away we've
increased their cost on their local
taxpayers and so this is a this is a
good faith commitment in this case to uh
try to keep them whole while we
transition into getting the kind of uh
stability that we really expect at the
Hamstead hospital I I don't I don't
think this precludes future
negotiations but I think it is um
fundamentally a reasonable transition
thing to
do and they've had to B had to hire two
more police officers
because of complaints represent Bean did
you have no
sirry further discussion on the motion
of ought to pass as amended on Senate
Bill
311 seeing none the clerk will call a
role on the motion of ought to pass as
amended thank you Mr chairman
representative Earth yes representative
Maguire
yes representative Petri votes yes
representative em yes representative
Griffin yes representative Mooney yes
representative Edwards yes
representative Bean yes Representative
hle
no representative Sweeney
yes representative camell yes representa
papovich Muller
yes represented waler yes representative
Grody yes representative Buco yes
representative Lane yes yes
representative uh Heath yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative eil yes represent torski
yes representative haen
Phillips
yes represent Stringham
yes representative grassy yes
representative priest yes representative
wer
yes Mr chair the vote is 24 to1 in favor
passes and I guess it goes on the
regular
count
okay was your question BL he's written
it already representative
string just written the report recognize
representative Edwards uh thank you Mr
or representative Wier I um
352 uh is a an important bill to uh uh
to highlight our support for the
increased risk that our uh active and
retired firefighters have taken on our
behalf um uh it it came to us as a good
bill uh we had some debate we came out
with an amendment uh that is uh an
amendment number I don't have in front
of me is this is this is the amendment
yes okay so the amendment number is 1
um uh this this amendment was discussed
it had bipartisan support within the
division three and and because it was
also simultaneously being coordinated
with the the involved community so I
think this has Community uh support and
and because of that I I I I would look
to uh representative tersi if you want
to offer an amendment or not an
amendment excuse me a motion
thank you very much um I'd like to make
a motion of a to pass with the intention
of introducing the
amendment is there a second second
motion and a second ought to
pass you recognize represent thank you
thank you very much Mr
chairman so Senate Bill
352 um comes to
us it was a very emotional hearing um
approximately 48 and a half percent of
firefighters will be diagnosed with some
form of cancer in their lifetime and
they have a 14% higher risk of dying
from cancer than the general
population occupational cancer is the
leading cause of line of duty deaths in
the fire service despite best practices
to reduce exposure to dangerous
chemicals the inherent risks of the job
are
unavoidable since we cannot eliminate
all risk this bill right here implements
an aggressive approach to detecting
cancer through a combination of blood
testing ultrasound and lung CT if needed
now the amendment was
drafted
um with the work of Representative
Mooney and an interest by representative
Lyon who was substituting at the
time um it basically does three things
um number one there's a language
correction um on line five of the
amendment
which um or I'm sorry line four to say
that um you can do a combination of one
or more of the following tests um which
means if you just want an ultrasound
that's fine but you're not mandated to
do all three
things um we are also removing the skin
cancer check that was included in the
bill because it was made clear to us
that skin cancer checks are available
through um Regular Insurance programs
and um the advocates for this bill were
good with that as a way to potentially
save money we also removed a $1300 per
person um individual cap because they
felt um that that could possibly limit
things when it comes to testing but we
did keep the overall cost of the bill
the same at a maximum cap of $5 million
so that does not
change
um and it add added the last
paragraph which
um calls for a report to be written um
after the program is completed to report
out on a variety of things as you can
see there the number of firefighters
that were screened the test conducted
the results Etc um that was something
that representative Lon felt very
strongly about so um this was the
Compromise amendment that we came up
and I'd be happy to speak a little bit
more about the bill but if we just want
to go ahead and move the amendment I can
that everyone had a chance to read the
amendment number 1
1915 all in favor of adopting the
hand unanimous hands down any opposed I
didn't see any thank you continue thank
you very much Mr chairman I just wanted
to now that we've adopted the amendment
um be clear that what this program is
going to do is potentially screen nearly
4,000 active duty firefighters and
retired firefighters um if they choose
to participate this is not a mandated
program at all um we really know that
early detection and screen in saves
lives um we heard from um we heard
testimony about a firefighter in my own
city of nasua um fire Lieutenant Jessica
Wyman and her passing due to
occupational cancer um that had not been
found just through regular physicals
whereas it's believed that with a
program such as this detection could
have been made early treatment could
have started much earlier
and um lives potentially could have been
saved
um this program will possibly deliver
life-saving intervention and treatment
before the disease has significantly
progressed and overall could potentially
reduce costs for patient employers and
insurance providers um to treat the
cancer early I urge the committee to
please support me in the ought to pass
as amended motion for Senate Bill 352
thank you further
discussion representative McGuire thank
you Mr chairman two questions uh what's
the general fund cost of this and I
heard you say when the program ends so
is this like a one-time screening or
every 10 years or something like
that um it is written into the bill it's
a pilot program with a maximum cap of
5,00
$5 million um so the intention is to
offer this program to those who want to
participate and yes it will end so sorry
May jump in there did you have a second
question I asked
two what your what was your second
question one was what's the cost and and
one was is it Ono I guess both of those
are answered yes
but but the the value of the report that
we added in the amendment is to document
the value and utility of the program and
it's been said that if we partner with a
clinical research facility we may
actually provide some information that
it'll be useful around the nation so so
this is viewed as a one-time project
with a report to tell us the value and
benefit of
it further
discussion seeing none clerk will call a
role on the motion of ought to pass as
amended by Amendment 1 191 5 on Senate
Bill
352 thank you Mr chairman representative
Earth yes yes representative Maguire yes
representative Petri votes yes
representative em yes representative
Griffin yes representative Mooney yes
representative Edwards yes
representative Bean yes representative
hle yes representative Sweeney yes
representative kimal yes representative
papichi Muller yes representa
walner representative Grody
yes representative buo yes
representative Lane yes representative
Heath yes representative Shapiro yes
representative evil yes represent torki
yes represent haen Phillips
yes representative Stringham yes
represent grassy yes representative
priest yes represent wer yes Mr chair
the vote is 25 to nothing in vote in
favor of the
motion and the motion V to pass as
amended is p is passed on Senate Bill
352 and I believe represent I'll submit
the majority report thank you thank
you representative Edwards for Senate
Bill
U thank you Mr chair um this is a the
355 is a Senate bill to uh create a new
screening program for a disease uh among
newborns that I'm not going to try to
pronounce it's you often referred to as
CMV um the I the idea here uh is that uh
this given that this is new uh we're
going to be asking bringing an amendment
forward uh at the request of the
hospital Association in anticipation
that we may pass this to change the
effective date so that they have an
additional six months after um passage
uh to uh prepare for everything that
they need to do in order to support the
Mandate that we're imposing on them so
um so I I'm going to ask uh
representative Mooney to elaborate and
and make a
motion thank you Mr chair I believe an
amendment at this point is being
distributed uh it should be an amendment
we've discussed several times inid three
and I can explain what it does assuming
I have the right document in front of
me thank
you thank you so this does do what I
want the effective minut there's no
this got two two
am okay I understand now what's going on
uh so I there are two amendments now in
front of everybody and I'm going to
advocate for both if that's that's okay
uh first of all I would like to move uh
the adoption of amendment number 20241
1878 H second thank you I'd like to
speak to that motion you recognize so
this bill uh Senate Bill 355 does three
things as amended assuming we adopt the
amendment that's in the motion right now
uh the first is that it directs the
commissioner of the Department of Health
and Human Services to amend a current a
rule
to require individuals conducting
newborn hearing screening and diagnostic
hearing evaluation reports to include
the results the results of the screening
if the infant does not
pass secondly the amendment in front of
you 1878 H allows parents to opt out of
CMV
screenings thirdly the amendment in
front of you directs the Department of
Health and Human Services to provide
information on the importance of early
detection through the newborn screening
program and include an update on
targeted newborn CMV screenings to the
oversight committee for inclusion in the
Department's annual
report that is what this amendment does
and I would ask for its
adoption motion to adopt Amendment 1878
on Senate Bill 355 is there any further
discussion seeing none will you accept
the hand hand count for the adoption of
hand hands down any
opposed okay you've adopted Amendment
1878 I believe the next Amendment amends
the effective date on that
Amendment yes I could certainly make
that motion I would move the adoption
now now of additionally amendment number
1934 H second Motion in a second
describe describe your Amendment thank
you uh representative walner first and
foremost is the sponsor of this
amendment but what it does is simply
changes the effective date through the
hospital Association and others that
have to actually Implement Senate Bill
355 this date is far more reasonable and
so for that I fully endorse the walner
amendment number 1934 H and ask that
everyone else adopt it too thank
Earth Mr Ripple can I just ask you a
question sure does it matter what order
we approve the amendments in the reason
I ask is the second one says replace
section two with the effective data and
section two is not the effective date
correct it's drafted this way because in
the bill in the unamended version of the
bill section two is the effective date
so if the committee were to pass both of
these we would combine them and it this
the effective date would replace section
three in the amendment thank
you thank you Mr chair thanks for
catching that representative hle so if I
understand Mr Ripple correctly there
would be a new amendment number merging
these two that would be the committee
Amendment that's correct
yes okay is everyone clear with
that okay represent Mooney's recognized
thank you at this point I would request
a vote then on amendment number 1934
hand hands down any
adopted and by the description they will
be
merged so I can now move a to pass as
representative walner for a
second yes representa walner
seconds further discussion I would just
add Mr chair this bill allocates only
$26,000 of taxpayer money from the
general funds to fund a portion of a
part-time position to implement the
policy within Senate Bill 355 thank
you further discussion on on Senate Bill
355 seeing none the clerk will call the
role on the motion of ought to pass as
amended on Senate Bill
355 thank you Mr chairman representative
R yes representative Maguire yes
representative Petri votes yes
representative Emer yes representative
Griffin yes representative
Mooney yes representative Edwards yes
representative Bean yes representative
hle yes representative Sweeney yes
representative C
yes repes representative papichi Muller
yes representative walner yes
representative Grody yes representative
buo yes representative Lane yes
representative Heath yes represent
Shapiro yes represent Vel yes represent
tki yes represent haen Phillips
yes representative Stringham yes
representative grassy yes
representative priest yes representative
wer yes Mr vote the chairman yeah Mr
chairman to B the vote is 25 to Z in
favor of the
motion h to pass as amended is adopted
for Senate Bill 355 moving on to page
two representative
Edwards uh thank you Mr chair um Senate
Bill 404 uh relative to expanding child
care professional eligibility for the
child care scholarship program uh
division 3 was unanimous in accepting uh
this with Amendment uh 1
1921 and so I would uh turn to
amendment and for the rest of division
three as this is going on I'm I'm I'm
turning to the people who committed to
writing the committee reports to make
good I'm just
so I move off to pass on um
Amendment
20241 921 h on Senate Bill 404
questions all in favor of adopting the
amendment please raise your
hand hands down any opposed motion is
wner so what the um under what the bill
does is it um profi provides that
um people who come to work in the child
care um sector would have their own
children eligible for the child care
scholarship
program child care has been having a
very very difficult time as you probably
all know from Reading um and hearing
about child care very hard time um
retaining and
um recruiting a Workforce and this is
just one tool that would be in the
toolbox of um employe
employers to attract employees to the
child care field so if a um
person was interested in being a child
care provider but they had young
children of their own and as you know
Child Care is very
expensive so they decide that they would
take a job in child care but they would
need assistance with their own child's
um tuition in the child care center or
the or with the family child care
provider
this bill would allow for there to be
some help for those families Child Care
tuition scholarships are on a sliding
fee scale so all families pay
something some pay more some pay less
depending on their income and their
family size um what the and the
um bill as WR the amendment actually
made made the eligibility up to median
income families with elig with incomes
up to median
income I'm glad to answer questions if
people have them questions from the
committee representative
Maguire thank you Mr chairman so yeah my
question for representative
wner are you saying that this makes um
child care providers eligible for the
program
and assuming that they otherwise
wouldn't be that their income is too
high to to otherwise qualify is that so
their income has to be between some kind
of level right below median but above
whatever the qualifies you is that right
yes in order to receive a child care
scholarship help paying for child care
you um it's under 85% of meet State
meeting
income for people going into the Vare
income further questions
representative thank you Mr chair can
you speak to the likelihood of the
Federal Department of Health and Human
Services granting the waiver so that
federal funds would cover the cost well
I certain I certainly have my fingers
crossed that that will happen um there
are other states that are looking at
this
and I believe actually it is Kentucky
where this is already taking place so I
think this is something that we're going
to see the federal government looking at
closely so I'm certainly um optimistic
that we will have this waiver or request
for a waiver
accepted we we do receive considerable
amount of funding for child care through
the federal government
further questions representative Mooney
thank you Mr chair I just want to point
out when this bill was originally
introduced the fiscal note for fiscal
year 2025 was between $18 to $26
million the house amended it in the
policy committee to be about 2.5 and now
it's down to a million covered likely by
federal funds I want to commend division
three I'll be voting for this amendment
okay I I believe we've adopted the
amendment now the next motion will be
ought to pass as amended representative
walner I'll move on to pass as
amended second second by repr solki
sersi
discussion representative Maguire thank
you Mr chairman so I'm going to vote for
this but I just want to point out that
programs like this can have negative
consequences in the sense that when you
put a cap on income to receive a benefit
that's an incentive not to ex to have
your income not exceed so I know in in
my business we have people who get
certain medical subsidies as long as
their income is below X so we ask them
to work extra hours they're not
interested because it would throw them
off their their benefits and that's kind
of thing could happen here in the same
way because now we're saying if your
income's below X median you won't you
will get this benefit if it's above you
won't so that's in it's going to have
some some negative
consequences representative cherski
thank you Mr chairman I just want to
point out that um the nature of this
bill is actually a win-win for um our
Workforce issue and our child care
crisis that the state is currently
experiencing if this bill passes and
attracts someone who is not in the work
workplace right now because they don't
have child care if they decide I can
become a child care worker I can reenter
the workforce have a little bit of
assistance in paying for my own child's
child care that adds a worker to a child
care center which allows the child care
center to then open up more spots for
children which allows more parents to
enter the workforce because there's more
places to put their children so I'll be
voting for this Bill thank you
further
discussion seeing none the clerk will
call the role on the motion of ought to
pass as amended by Amendment 1921 on
404 thank you Mr chairman representative
F yes representative Maguire yes
representative Petri VZ representative
am yes representative Griffin yes
representative Mooney yes representative
Edwards yes representative Bean yes
Representative hle
no representative Sweeney
yes representative camell yes represent
papich Muller yes representative
walner yes representative Grody yes
representative buo yes representative
Heath is
okay representative Shapiro
yes representative eil yes
representative Tori yes represent haen
Phillips yes represent Stringham yes
representative grassy yes representative
priest
yes representative Wier
yes Mr chairman the vote is 231 in favor
of the
representative Edwards Senate Bill 406
yes sir um Senate Bill 406 uh this is
just to keep everyone on their toes uh
this is uh about making an appropriation
to the department to increase rates for
shelter programs and division 3 uh had
recommended an itl on this um um along
party lines what uh we've gotten some
new information though from uh the
chairman who attended an arpa meeting
and said that the uh arpa funds would be
available to support this and I believe
Mr Ripple is passing out an amendment to
saying such a thing and and because we
have a funding source for this albe it a
a one-time funding source um it may it
may change some minds of um the the
people who considered this in division
three
I'll be I'll be going when when that
gets handed out I recommend we go to
representative
Stringham oh no not
Stringham uh
[Music]
representative
hle I was the person who made the motion
itl so maybe someone else wants to make
the motion if it's with the amendment I
would I would like to move Rec consider
since this is for the negotiation status
with the Senate the Senate tacked this
on to the arpa funds and they they place
this as a priority they heard testimony
we did not hear when we heard the bill
that some fairly large shelter in
Manchester said they would close if they
didn't get this extra money on a daily
basis and it was I think 100 beds up for
grabs so the Senate heard that I don't
know why that same person didn't come
and speak to us but we didn't hear him I
think all the testimony we heard people
were fairly happy with going up from 8
to 20 so we decided we didn't need the
extra money but now he's insisted that
he wants to use this money and and he
wants to uh pass this bill and add the
25 per day versus the 20 per day to the
people that provide shelter so so
representative wer I I'd like to make a
motion to adopt uh your Amendment
2024 1866 well I think first we've got
to reconsider the itl motion no you no
there's no motion before the committee
that was at a subcommittee all right
that was a recommendation all right go
ahead I would like to move uh we we we
pass Amendment uh 1866
Hotel all right a motion to
adopt uh Amendment
1866 further discussion
seeing none all in
favor you have a representative ver if
somebody can speak to so the bill had a
subsection two under part one and which
here am I the wrong Bill no you get the
right one it says she'll not know ly
provide services to any person but
prioritize veterans Mr chair and shall
not knowingly provide services to any
person not legally president of the
United
States still there just replacing this
just
replacing this is just replacing
paragraph one paragraph one the rest of
that's still
there further
questions all right all in favor of
hand hands down any
opposed Mo the amendment is
adopted M Mr chair I I would like to um
make a motion to adopt uh Senate Bill
406 with Amendment 20241
1866 second okay motion by Edwards
second was
tersi to ought to pass as amended by
Amendment 1866 on Senate Bill 406 Is
discussion seeing none the clerk will
call the role on the motion of ought to
pass as amended on Senate Bill
406 thank you Mr
chairman representative F yes
representative Maguire yes
representative Petri votes yes
representative Emer yes representative
Griffin yes representative Mooney yes
representative Edwards yes
representative Bean yes representative
hole
no representative Sweeney
yes representative camell yes
representative papich Muller
no representative waler yes represent
Grody yes represent buo yes represent
Lane yes representative Heath
yes representative
Shapiro yes
represent evil yes represent torki yes
representative haen Phillips yes
represent Stringham
yes represent grassy yes represent
priest yes represent Wier
yes Mr chair the vote is 23-2 in favor
adopted representa Edwards uh yes sir I
I just want to clarify who's going to be
writing the committee report um and if
there's going to be uh a Minority Report
on that because we we flipped from what
the division was thinking I don't know
who's writing all right we'll work that
out is there a Minority Report no
Minority
Report were you raising your hand to
write the I would volunteer if anyone if
no one else from division three would
thank you thank you um there is no
okay so Mr chair um I would like to uh
introduce SP 409 to the committee this
is relative to reimbursement for
ambulance services under the Medicaid
plan this
passed uh easily I think out of uh
division three with an amendment
1860 and uh I would I would ask
representative Stringham for a motion
amended you're recognized to
explain thank you uh ambulance services
have become an increasingly important
Cog in the granite State's healthc care
system and under great financial stress
a significant portion of an ambulance's
Services calls do not lead to the
transport from one location to another
and therefore are not reimbursed an
example ex of such a service is an
emergency call where an ambulance is
dispatched to a location to assist an
individual suffering from a drug
overdose the ambulance provider drives
to the scene delivers Naran saves the
person's life and the ambulance returns
to its station with no transport under
current Medicaid rules ambulance
companies providing such Services would
not receive any
reimbursement s sp49 provides an
appropriation of $500,000 of General
funds to compensate ambulance providers
for non-transport medical services for
Medicaid patients and begin the process
to become eligible for payment from
CMS thank
you represent M thank you Mr chairman
since I am not part of division three I
have worked for a medical uh service
provider and I know that there are a lot
of services you provide that you don't
get reimbursed for and therefore
the uh charges that you issue for other
services tend to account for those
unpaid Services my question would be was
there any discussion on whether adopting
this and filling a gap in the billing
structure would result in the ambulance
Services overall reducing other rates to
compensate for this well unfortunately
at this time when we when we began this
by anym we had four ambulance service
companies go out of business in the
first three months of last year uh
there's still great uh Financial stress
even at this current level of
reimbursement overall there's
approximately 11.5 million of Medicaid
payments for ambulance services this is
definitely new money on top of that uh
the the there's not any anticipation of
decreasing the reimbursement of the
other rates and the other rates are
probably still insufficient to cover the
cost as uh this service model continues
its
transformation uh from being volunteer
firefighters to professional uh medical
service
technicians further discussion I'm
delighted we have some experience on the
committee in this areas representative
hacken Phillips thank you Mr chair I do
know uh this is particularly relevant
for smaller communities supporting these
Services uh you might you might imagine
that larger um cities or towns that have
multiple ambulatory services and calls
with a large budget may not not feel the
effects of uh as much as smaller towns
with smaller budgets so you know one
ride two rides can really blow up um you
know their expectation of what they're
they're going to be spending on these
services so um I really think this is
something our rural communities can
benefit from and I support the motion
thank you representative Mooney oh thank
you Mr chairman um an amendment was just
distributed and it's numbered
1862 h from our sheet 1860 H so I would
like to move uh the adoption of
amendment
1862 H which is the proper Amendment it
adds the uh appropriation to the bill
that was missing as discovered in
division three so I would request a
second to that motion and then uh a vote
thank you second we have a second and it
it's clear this replaces the previous
Amendment
I don't know what amendment number
186 is Mr Ripple can you comment I think
it's just a mistake on the sheet I think
1862 H was the correct Amendment all
along oh it is oh
okay it's just a correction in the the
numbering of the amendment all those in
favor of adopting Amendment 1862 raise
your
hands hands down any
opposed that motion is adopted
and now we go to representative
motion he's probably got the report
written well I I would say pretty you
know uh what I said before still holds
so nothing nothing else to add to that
you move off to pass as I move off to
pass as amended with
right further discussion on on the vote
of ought to pass as amended on Senate
Bill
409 seeing none the clerk will call a
role on the motion of ought to pass as
amended by Amendment 1862 on Senate Bill
409 thank you Mr chairman representative
Earth yes representative McGuire
representative Petri votes yes
representative Emer yes representative
Griffin yes representative Mooney yes
representative Edwards yes
representative Bean yes was that yes yes
I'm sorry um representative hle yes
representative Sweeney yes represent
camell yes represent papovich
Muller
yes represent walner yes represent grod
yes representative buo yes
representative Lane yes I'm
sorry
yes just making sure representative
Heath yes represent Shapiro yes
represent vble yes represent torski yes
represent hien Phillips
yes represent Stringham yes
representative grassy yes representa
priest yes representative wer yes Mr
chair the vote is 25 to zero in favor of
the motion motion is adopted on Senate
Bill
409 representative Edwards uh thank you
Mr chair uh I I want to check in with um
Mr Ripple to make sure I'm talking about
the correct Amendment here uh
representative Hull had a a late
breaking Amendment um relative to uh
4177 do do do we do we have that
available to us so I I believe the
amendment for 417 number 1923 was the
one that was voted on in division three
earlier today U is that consistent with
what the division three members okay oh
good good thank you um so uh so
representative H can uh talk to his
Amendment and uh it it does a it does a
couple of things that uh are are pretty
pivotable so uh representative H do you
want to speak sure thank you so um for
the purpose of discussion I move 2024
1923 H as an amendment to Senate Bill
417 I will quickly summarize the changes
um the the purpose of this bill is to
prioritize making sure that we can place
children who are in danger of harm or
neglect um with some sort of instate
placement um family as opposed to an
instate placement in a in a facility
like a um either a hotel or a group home
um or even worse yet would be out of
state the the changes are as follows in
lines 24 through 30 it changes the
presumption that an app parent who has
not been charged with abuse or neglect
is presumed innocent and deemed a fit
parent and that the dcyf or the
department can challenge that in and
call for a court hearing um it raises
the bar from a propond of evidence to
clear and convincing evidence which is
the standard that we use in other
sections in our statutes relative to um
both civil and criminal cases um there
was an a fair amount of discussion
within our division on that next um is
page two it makes changes um it adopts
an amendment that was proposed by the
chairman wer it makes changes in line
five instead of just unique needs it it
describes unique and and quantifies that
to be physical mental emotional or
medical needs of the child and then in
lines 13 through
17 it incentivizes the parent to
cooperate with the Department instead of
penalizing the department the the parent
in failure to cooperate with the
department and it reads a parent
cooperation with the Department's
assessment or their effort to provide
any records necessary to such
determination shall be weighed as a
factor in favor of the fitness of the
parent um moving away from a penalty
based system of working with parents to
a um rewards based system would be
better um and then it makes minor tweaks
relative to the language of adult this
is line 29 um with related adult or kin
as defined in RSA 170 25 Roman numeral 8
and that was discussed at length within
our our committee or
division um this gives the judicial
branch some ability to make sure that
the best interests of the child are
taken care
of and that is done throughout the bill
um relative to that change of kin versus
fictive kin which was in the the prior
version representative Edwards uh thank
you Mr chair representative hle you you
put this uh on page two um lines 16 17
and 18 the fact that parent owns a
firearm shall not make a home unsafe nor
be weighed against the parent could
could you explain what the motivation of
why that's important to have in there
are we uh experiencing issues where a
gun has caused a poor
determination so thank you I I apologize
to the committee for not bringing that
up it is a significant change um we have
seen evidence in looking at the bridges
files where the the mere presence of a
firearm is now weighed against a parent
um ownership or or possession should not
be we already have under our current
650c right an entire chapter of law
relative to negligent storage of
firearms so if the if the family is
misusing or mis storing a firearm it's
already a a criminal um a violation of
criminal code and is at a misdemeanor or
felony level so obviously we're not
talking about failure to store these
correctly we're talking about the mere
presence of one in the home or that the
parent owns one and we've seen enough
evidence that that is an issue that this
that this amendment would correct that
to make sure that that is not a baseline
you further discussion representative
tersi thank you very much Mr chair I do
um have a problem with which with a
couple parts of this but I'll just point
out to
um page
two line
five where the whole Amendment says um
the unique physical mental emotional and
medical needs of the child the original
Bill
said the unique needs of the child and
whether or not the parent parent is
adequately prepared to address those
needs and I believe removing the section
about if a parent is adequately prepared
to address the needs is problematic the
reason why this section is so important
is if we reflect on the harmony
Montgomery case we all know that case
very very well and Harmony Montgomery
had unique needs she had unique
um developmental needs and it is clear
that her
parent was not prepared to address those
needs so I feel removing that section
there is really problematic um in that
circumstance which we all know so well
the other thing um with that section is
representive whole went on to list
physical mental emotional
medical what does he missing there's not
educational in there a child may have
educational needs that we need to
address um when considering the best
place for a child so that's my problem
with that
section um and then regarding the
firearm um line on page 17 um I
understand the you know the there's a um
safe storage um statute already um but
there are circum cumstances
where um perhaps there is a history of
domestic violence in the home or if um
you know there are other outstanding
circumstances where having a firearm in
the home is problematic I'm not saying
owning a firearm removes your right of
being able to provide a safe home for
your child not at all but I do believe
that there are unique circum again
there's that word unique circumstances
and we need to keep those that option
available um so I I cannot support this
amendment thank you I think at the top
of page two that paragraph 1A does the
same thing as what was left out in
a Mr Sher if I may speak to it go ahead
thank you um in lines two and three it
says in determining whether a parent is
pit to fit to perform his or her
duties um I think that is in fact the
exact language that we would need
relative to a and the reason we captured
physical mental emotional and medical
are those are physical physical
attributes we can at some level measure
and
quantify um and while the member from
nashille brings up educational and I'm
not horribly opposed to adding that to
this list um I I do think we needed a
Quantified list
there further discussion representative
Edwards uh thank you Mr chair uh to
representative's concern about uh
flexibility I I read at the line uh page
two lines 1 through four as providing a
tremendous amount of emphasis on the the
child's welfare and also saying that the
following factors should be considered
in addition to any other relevant
evidence presented so so although there
is a list there this list is is not
meant to be incl exclusive this list is
meant to be you know a sort of a minimal
standard of considerations while leaving
the door open to any other
considerations that are relevant to the
determining the welfare of the
child represent
walner thank you Mr
chair so this kind of amendment is
exactly what scares me when it comes to
making legislation at the last minute
um this came in there are significant
very
significant um changes to our laws in
this piece of legislation we did not
have public input on it we did not have
the department speak to this amendment
to tell us how this would affect their
work uh we did have
um a a representative from the court who
did speak briefly on on it um there are
some very significant changes to law and
I will just bring up the one that um
sort of jumps out at me at least is we
are
changing um how cases um go before the
court um and we're changing from
preponderance of the evidence
preponderance of to clear and convincing
evidence and that is a very serious
serious move for us to be making here at
the last minute we actually saw this
amendment I think um sometime around
noon today and I think it's not a way
not a good way for us to make
legislation particularly when the woman
from the court even told us that this
means that fewer cases will come before
the before the court and this has the
potential and we do not know the number
we this has the potential of putting
children in danger and I think we have
to think very long and hard before we
make these kinds of decisions without
the right
information further discussion represent
Hull thank you Mr chair if I I may
respond to that if I bring up one of the
sections of the guidelines relative to
guardianship of minors and what is the
process and this is a document that I
have pulled from um our State website
it says and I quote if however a person
seeking guardianship is not the parent
of a minor that person must prove by
clear and convincing evidence that the
best interests of the minor require
substitution or supplementation of
Parental care and the supervision to
provide the essential physical and
safety needs of the minor or to present
specific or significant psychological
harm to the minor the reason I bring
that up is we are using this standard in
child welfare cases already there's
other places within our statutes that we
use both preponderance of of evidence as
well as clear and convincing um it's in
the rules within the department under
H 20 h-c
20314 standards of burden of proof so
what's been changed here is to minimize
the roadblocks to getting a child into a
home where the parent or or Guardian
wasn't charged or with any right this is
where the pro the respective
home the the parents are have not had
any issues with dcyf so why are we
making it that much harder to move
children into these new homes I would
think we would want to incentivize this
instead of warehousing them in hotel
rooms or group homes where there's a
much higher likelihood for abuse so this
just means that DCF has a slightly
higher burden and to prove that they
can't the children can't move to this
new home represent Gro thank you uh Mr
chair I realized that this is only my
second day on this committee however I
must tell you that once again I'm going
to throw up the policy card because this
is not a financial decision I'm sorry to
say up until now I've been very diligent
in making sure that I understand the
financial implications and you've and
I've learned a lot however this policy
belongs either in judiciary or or child
of family law it does not belong here
and I I can understand the the interest
but I really cannot support an amendment
that is strictly policy which this
is I just I can't support that and I
would hope that you would all recognize
that your as your perview because you
have your strength and other committees
have their strength and furthermore this
is a kind of Bill that needs a hearing
with everyone's input this is a serious
deal thank you further discussion
representative Hull thank you Mr chair
um I would like to bring up the docket
for this bill because this bill came
from the Senate and went to the house
and children and family law had a
discussion on this and they proposed an
amendment that was defeated on the floor
by a vote of 175 in favor and 188
opposed subsequently I moved to table it
so we could have start having these
discussions and that narrowly failed by
184 um yes there is some policy things
but the policy change relative to
section 3 is important because it
minimizes the number of Court hearings
that are going to happen by changing the
presumption that this is a fit parent to
move the children
into representative
Stringham I I think I fall in line with
those to keep the language as a
preponderance of the evidence uh the
um you know there's obviously a
trade-off of risk of of uh of a fit
parent uh losing access to a child
versus a child being put in a perilous
um potentially life-threatening
situation and I I think clear and
convincing evidence is just uh you know
there's there's not a camera go what's
going on in these households 24 hours a
day I still think it's a very very high
bar that's uh uh that's used very
judiciously and and without Committee
hearing
and and experts voicing on it um I'm
going to vote against the amendment and
in support of the preponderance of the
evidence language thank
you further
discussion we've just had two people
leave all right one's coming back should
we wait for the other one yes all
right all right we have a full
committee there's no further discussion
the the clerk will call the role on the
motion of ought to pass as amended
Senate Bill 47 the amendment first Mr
chairman wait a minute Amendment
13 to
adopted representative H is recognized
for a motion I move to pass um Senate
Bill 47 with the amendment 1923
H motion is not to pass as amended
Amendment 1923 on Senate Bill 417 second
and a second may may I make an
observation certainly um th this bill
covers some of the same terrain that we
covered in house bill 1573 that division
3 looked at went over to the Senate uh
Senate has passed us and sent it to us
um if if we get a positive floor vote on
uh House Bill 417 as amended it's not
done what'll happen is uh Committee of
conference will probably be
required I re recommend that we pass
this further discussion seeing none the
clerk will call the role on the motion
of ought to pass as amended by Amendment
1923 on Senate Bill
417 motion is ought to pass as Amendment
thank you Mr chairman representative F
yes representative Maguire yes
representative Petri votes yes
representative Emer yes representative
Griffin yes representative Mooney yes
representative Edwards yes
representative Bean yes representative
hle yes representative Sweeny yes
representative Campell yes rep
representative papichi Muller yes
Representative walner no Representative
groy
no uh Representative buo no
representative Lane no represent of
Heath represent of ship Piro no
represent of eil
no Representative torki no
representative haken Phillips
no representative Stringham
no representa grassy no represent Priest
No represent wer yes Mr chairman the
vote is 13 to 12 in favor of the motion
motion is
adopted representative Edwards send a
bill 455 yes yes sir on 417 I I I
presume representative hle will write
the committee report and who Minority
Report represent priest would like to
write the
minority and priest what's the motion
it's not a motion it's just a signing no
Report itl itl yes okay thank
you I assume that but I'm sorry I don't
believe the motions
to
o
oh okay so U thank thank you Mr chair
um I'd like to um introduce Senate Bill
455 relative to Medicaid reimbursement
rates for uh prosthetic and orthotic
devices um this came out of the
committee with a the unanimous support
based on Amendment
1924 um that has since uh been subject
to one more Amendment so I don't have
and then my name is on the amendment um
would you like me to speak the amendment
please uh uh thank you Mr chair uh
Amendment 20241 958 H um uh on line six
uh establishes a Medica a Medicaid
reimbursement rate dependent upon a
Medicare reference and in order to make
that reference uh fixed the date of
January 1
2024 was uh selected um because those
rate changes come out as frequently is
quarterly so as a using that as our
Benchmark we said that U the
reimbursement rate for Medicaid should
be 90% of that uh in order to avoid uh a
a a constant escalation in that um rate
over time uh we we left it at 90% of
that Benchmark as of that day this bill
appropriates uh $620,000
uh to uh get get the uh rate re um
implemented and and begin reimbursement
of
it so I I would uh I would move
acceptance of the amendment 198 1958
second motion and a second for uh
Amendment 1958 to Senate Bill
4555 further discussion all in favor of
adopting the amendment please raise your
hand
hands down any
opposed motion is the amendment is
adopted and and then um for a motion of
otpa i' I'd refer to representative
Stringham yes I uh for the motion uh
Senate Bill 4555 is amended ought to
pass further discussion second
second seeing none uh yeah I can make
comment uh this bill provid provides a
supplemental appropriation to the
Medicaid payment rates for prosthetic
and orthotic devices needed and used by
Medicaid patients these medical devices
include back and knee braces Orthotics
and over 600 categories of products to
help correct injured or malformed body
body parts uh the current payment rate
according to DHHS is 80% of uh the full
Medicaid rate table uh this supplemental
appro ration would provide an increase
to most uh most products and a reduction
in a few so that the payment rate
adjustment will now come to 90% of the
Medicare rates as of January 1 uh such
increases are needed as low payment
rates as created increased access issu
issues uh the Medicare base rate also
serves as an more accurate uh base for
reimbursement for these essential
services uh this increase represents the
floor payment that our New Hampshire
Medicaid contractors can pay for these
covered uh prostatic and orthotic
Services thank
you thank you further discussion seeing
none the clerk will call a role on the
motion of ought to pass as amended
Senate Bill 455 as amended by Amendment
1958 thank you Mr chairman
representative Earth yes representative
McGuire yes representative Petri votes
yes representative Emer yes
representative Griffin yes
representative Mooney yes representative
Edwards yes representative Bean yes
representative hle yes representative
Sweeny yes representative camell yes
representative papichi Muller yes
representative
walner yes representative groy yes
representative buo yes representative
Lane yes representative Heath yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative evil yes representative
torski yes representative haaken
Phillips yes representative Stringham
yes representative grassy yes
representative
priest yes representa Wier yes Mr chair
the vote is 25 to Z in favor of the
motion motion is adopted moving on to
Senate Bill
456 uh thank you Mr chair uh Senate Bill
456 relative to State loan repayment
program for qualified nursing
professionals and making an
appropriation there um the division
three U recommended OTP nine to nothing
uh you you you were the one in the
committee that made that initial um uh
motion um would you would would you like
to take this discussion at this point
sir or do you want me yes I will thank
you so the HHS came before us this is a
program that's been in existence for
quite a while they referred us to the
slrp the state loan repayment program uh
it's for nurses working in underserved
areas um and they had a r the modest
request for
300,000 because the the fund was running
a little short and they wanted to keep
uh that incentive going for the for the
areas that needed nurses so we
unanimously adopted it and I move ought
second further discussion I I I have
discussion representative Edwards uh
thank you Mr chair and I I I hate to do
this to my division 3 counterparts uh
but the longer I thought about this um
Bill the less and less I I liked it uh
the $300,000 does in fact supplement an
existing program uh it was said in
testimony that that 300,000 would cover
uh funds for six people who are serving
in underserved areas and as I started
thinking about it the state would grant
them a $500,000
or excuse me a $50,000 bonus those six
people to work in an area where the
median
income probably isn't $50,000 and so it
just felt to me feels to me now uh like
a heavy Distortion of economic benefit
being
assigned into an area of the state that
um has has a lot of E economic issues
and and and while I want to provide some
relief I'm not convinced this program
was the right way to do that so I'll
I'll be voting no representative thank
you Mr chairman I just want to provide a
little more information about what this
bill actually does um this is a bill
that will attract Workforce of nurses
and medical professionals to an area
that's underserved in testimony we heard
primarily what we are talking about here
is Coos County it's really hard to get
young nursing graduates uh to say I'm
going to go start my life up in Coos
County if they're graduating from say
Rivier University in nasua or St anum's
nursing school in Manchester what this
is is a bit of an incentive for them to
move to Coos County to participate in
the program they sign a contract that
they are going to work up there for an
extended period of time I believe it was
three three years um the program at
$300,000
would provide at minimum they said
program to six nurses however when you
run the numbers of what those six nurses
can do over the course of those years
we're talking about
25,000 patient visits 25,000 patient
visits up in Coos County that would not
be able to happen otherwise without
these people up there six nurses may not
sound like a lot but when we're talking
about 25,000 patient visits for kids
with ear infection for strep throat
visits all of those things we need these
people up there I think it's a strong
program we already know it works because
it's an ongoing program I am going to
vote Yes on the motion about about to
pass thank you further discussion
representative
Shapiro yes thank you Mr chairman and um
this bill came before Health and Human
Services committee and what we heard in
our committee when people testified on
this bill is that it would um
serve six to 10 full-time nurses and up
to 17 part-time nurses um this is a
program that um as was already stated is
in existence for a long time um and
serves Physicians nurses a whole host of
um medical providers but this money
would just be earmarked for nurses
because there's a particular Acuity of
um
you know in Workforce shortages of
um I just I'm going to support this bill
because I think it is re it's not enough
it's insufficient um it's not going to
resolve our whole Workforce shortage but
for those providers for those hospitals
or nursing homes that are having to pay
um traveling nurses this will make a
significant difference if they can keep
permanent
employees thank you further
discussion seeing none the motion is
ought to pass on Senate Bill
456 clerk will call a role on that
motion thank you Mr chairman
representative ver
no representative McGuire no
representative Petri votes no
representative em
yes representative Griffin
no representa Mooney
yes representative Edwards
no representative Bean
no Representative hle no representative
Sweeny
no Representative camell
no representa papovich Muller no
represent walner
yes represent Grody yes representative
buo yes represent l
yes yes representative Heath yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative Vil yes representative
torski yes representative haaken
Phillips
yes representative Stringham yes
representative grass seat
yes representative priest yes
representative Wier
yes Mr chairman the vote is 15 to10 in
favor of the motion
report is
adopted i' I'd like to write The
Minority Report okay you will write a
Minority Report thank you and the motion
is itl my my motion will be itl yes
thank you okay I'll be writing the
majority unless representative cherski
wants to write
it majority report that's okay sir if
your name's on it that's great I I'd
rather you didn't do that Mr chair I
it's bad enough that we're disagreeing
in
public would you write the report
please
sure rep uh Senate Bill
463 uh thank you uh Mr chair Senate Bill
463 uh expanding access to court
appointed counsel um we
uh discuss this and want to uh recommend
to the committee o
otpa um and a pretty wide vote um and
then there is a new Amendment that's
with a number that's
TBD uh and is representative walner are
you going to talk to this are you going
to tell us whether you think this latest
not I'm just going to point out that the
one I'm handing out now in 1948 is the
one that was discussed in
represent does have an alternative
version
Don't okay so so you couldn't hear that
so the version being handed out is 1948
this is the version that was discussed
and voted on out of division three and
I'll I'll defer to even though it's got
my name on it I'll defer to represent
walner do you
yeah okay PA hold your hat because this
is GNA be a little confusing
okay so when we heard this bill this is
um about courta appointed lawyers for
children and
um there was a concern brought up that
it's very it you know it's it's really
challenging in this market to find
enough lawyers to do this
work
so we tried some we tried some language
about what to do about that um and then
over the weekend we were I worked with
some folks around developing a phase in
process so what will happen is on July 1
of
2025 all children will be all children
in residential care they're in the
custody of the state they live in a
residential facility all th all of those
children will be eligible for a Loy to
have a
lawyer there are about
124 25 of those children we don't know
exactly how many there'll be on um July
1 of 2025 but it will probably be in
that that round
range imagine trying to find on that day
125 lawyers
probably really a big
steep
um for us to do so what we did was we on
page two of the amendment you'll see at
the bottom we did a phase in so we
phased in the oldest
children then the next and the next and
the next taking a year to make sure that
every child who was in residential care
had a
lawyer the other thing that we did in
this amendment was we
um made sure that children who were out
England had a lawyer so children placed
in outof state placements and we do have
some not many we're working on getting
that number down but we do have some
children who are in outof state
placements
and right under the phase down on page
two you'll
see I'll read this paragraph to you not
withstanding this subparagraph in any
action in which despite diligent efforts
to secure counsel an attorney is not
available for appointment litigation May
proceed until an attorney becomes
available in such cases the court shall
where
possible
prioritize consideration of legal issues
that do not affect the child's expressed
interest until an attorney becomes
available so we will have the phase down
we will have the phase down but if we're
just not able to accomplish it we do
have this paragraph well what happened
is there's a drafting error probably my
fault um um and I will tell you where
that is if you turn to your bill and you
look at line8 of page two you'll also
there see notwithstanding the above it
does not fit there that's not where it
belongs it belongs Down Below on line
35 okay so it needs to come out of there
then in reading it a little further
again it appears on line 18 on page
three not withstanding the
above that's not where this belongs it
belongs it belongs in L on line 35 under
the phase down it refers to the phase
down not withstanding the
above so what we have here is a little
bit of a mess um
I do have an amendment that takes it out
of that fixed it up to line eight took
it out
there but I didn't turn the page and see
that in line on page three it also
repeated it and then we found that so I
don't know how the chairman would like
to proceed at this
point my amend my Amendment takes it out
in one place um but now there are two
places
may I may I offer repres Edward I I I I
want to um thank representative walner
for all the work that she's put into
this um it it may feel chaotic and
unsettled to people that would like uh
this to be more stable by now um but I
think the issue is that we've all been
trying very hard to work very quickly to
get the very best bill we can and I
appreciate representative walner
stepping in I I I I think in the past
we've accepted an amendment noting
technical uh Corrections or or um the
other word
um grammatical fixes and I I I assume
that these the the fixes that
representative walner just alluded to
could fall into that category but I
would look to Mr Ripple to say if if if
if these Corrections could be accepted I
think if the committee were so inclined
you could take a vote to adopt
1948 with the understanding that I would
remove the sentence that begins with
notwithstanding on page two lines 8- 12
22 that's what my recommendation to you
would be Mr
chair would they get moved to somewhere
else or are they just not needed where
they
are just I think representative Walter's
recommendation is that they're not
needed where they are the phrase would
remain on page
two beginning on line 35 yeah that's
where we decided it did belong yes just
okay you have a question representative
papichi thank you just to make sure I
understand because there is a lot of um
changes we would be removing essentially
starting with a word not withstanding
the above and then the next four lines
both on starting on line 8 page two and
then the line 18 page three current line
numbers that's what we are talking about
that not just the words not withstanding
the above the whole phrase four four
lines wor thank you I I just want you to
make sure I understood it was needed in
one place but it got put more we're
yeah Mr
chair representa hle thank you um so in
addition um to the removal that was
discussed by the member from conquer
there's a small tweak that we should
make in whatever this proposed amendment
is which is relative to the repeal date
because the repeal date deletes a small
reference in line 29 on page one
relative to this phase in schedule well
the phasin schedule is repealed but we
leave in statute part of 28 and 29 so I
would also propose that we clean that up
I think this amendment actually does
that it's section three on page three
line five uh this replaces 169 C10 um
after after paragraph 2E is repealed it
would read this way that's why the
phrase subject to the phase uh phase in
schedule establish in sub paragraph 2 C
out yeah so this is the version of
Statute that would
remain after to the repeal of the other
paragraph
occurs I understand that prospective
repeal on page three lines right
sections five and six my concern is
right in What We Leave Behind is Roman
numeral
2B um I believe stays around referencing
sub paragraph 2E but sub paragraph 2E
doesn't live so on page three okay
section three of the bill oh oh that's
sorry I didn't catch that new section
yeah that's the new version that would
exist that would no longer reference to
e okay got it thank you and that's also
that's why the phrase notwithstanding
the above ends up appearing multiple
times in the amendment thank you
understood all right is the situation
for amending the amendment
clear and um
when it goes to press that will be the
amendment that goes with it Mr
Ripple whatever the number may be how
many people find that those Corrections
that Mr Ripple will make acceptable in
adopted somebody move the motion and
second
okay representative wner you wish to
move the amendment as
amended yes I wish to move the amendment
as amended thank you I'll second her
amended Amendment all
hands hands down v
a one and amended amendment is adopted
and we'll move on to a motion of to pass
as
amended
representative who makes the motion I
head down here representative priest did
you have a report written yes I do okay
then you can make the
motion yes I move that we
approve ought to pass sb46 63 as
amended second second
by who
seconded Mooney representative Mooney
okay as printed further discussion on
the on Senate Bill 463 representative
Maguire thank you Mr chairman I'm going
to refrain on making any comments about
legislating in the finance
committee but but I'd like to ask I I'm
not sure I understand what the bill does
so is this a bill that for children that
already have Guardians at Lim they will
also get an attorney maybe in some cases
and if so how many attorneys are we
talking about and and what's the the
cost of those attorneys and is it all
general fund money or is it from other
sources thank
you who would like to
answer representative H do you have any
answer I I will I will take a shot at
that um it's a policy change um that I
have argued for in children and family
law before in a different Bill currently
children have a Casta assigned or and or
a g assigned but in both of those cases
they are not representing the expressed
interests of the
child and we experienc personally
through um various things that happened
a couple years ago that a 13-year-old
might be
the subject of a court proceeding and
never have their own wishes showed up in
show up in the courtroom and there's no
way for them to to make that happen and
in this case allowing the party that has
the most skin in the game to have an
attorney representing their expressed
interest is valuable
policy um uh there are concerns about
how to do the training and the costs and
the ramp in and all of that's been
discussed and I I I do think the the
member from conquer figured out at least
some solution to start to do this for a
small group of children who are
currently in in out of home
placements I do think long term this
needs to be expanded to all children
that are being removed from their home
the the kid who's going to be removed
should have some say in where he ends up
and currently they're not capable of
even getting into the courtroom let
alone having their expressed
wishes and I think that is an incredibly
valuable policy change that we are doing
for our children so while not perfect
and it's it's a little bit of a last
minute hurdle um and I don't necessarily
agree with all of the underlying
assumptions that are in part one of the
bill I do believe that this is the right
step forward as a small incremental
question I didn't hear any dollar amount
in that there was no dollar amount and I
do think that we're going to have to
figure out the additional costs relative
to the to the assignment of the
attorneys um but children are
effectively not capable of paying
financially and in all those cases in
the court process we routinely assign
attorneys to represent those who can't
pay themselves the the testimony we
heard from people involved in this area
there was also an the original bill 14
additional child protective service
workers which have been eliminated that
people that spoke about it said what do
you need all those people for so we took
them out and it was the biggest saving
14 positions representative Edwards uh
thank you I I think what representative
McGuire's wanting is kind of a financial
accounting answer and I'm going to I'm
going to give you a managerial
accounting answer instead um in the
population of about 1,200 uh affected
youth um the number affected by this
bill is about
120 and of that 120 the estimated cost
per
uh a placement is about
$300,000 so the so an idea is if out of
that
120 if even just three of them get
directed in a less expensive way that's
also probably more appropriate to the
child then then that would generate
internally some
savings that that is a theory uh that I
will figure out if it works that
way answer your
discussion seeing none the clerk will
call a role on the motion of ought to
pass as amended for Senate Bill
463 motion by priest second by
Mooney thank you Mr chairman
representative F yes representative
Maguire yes
representative Petri votes
yes representative Emer yes
representative Griffin yes
representative Mooney yes representative
Edwards yes representative Bean yes
representative hle yes representative
Sweeney yes representative Campell yes
representative Popovich Muller yes
representative
walner yes representative Grody yes
representative buco yes representative
Lane yes representative Heath yes
representative shipiro yes
representative Evel yes represent torski
yes represent hen Phillips yes is that a
yes yes very good why yes I can't hear
you representative Stringham yes
representative grassie
yes representative priest yes
representative wer yes Mr chair the vote
is 25 to Z in favor of the motion motion
is adopted but to pass as amended
awaiting the amendment
final representative Edwards uh thank
you Mr chair um s SP 499 I'd like to
check with Mr Ripple there was a
possibility of Representative hle
submitting a study committee
amendment I have an amendment for
representative po yes so I have three
amendments to this bill the one that was
originally adopted in division 3 uh last
week or earlier this week 1650 yes I
have an amendment from representative
tersi and I have an amendment from
representative po I I Mr Sher I'd
recommend you just pass out all three of
them do they all meld together nicely no
there's
um this this is fun there it's going to
be a little conflict
here all right
what's the first discussion I I would
say that the first discussion ought to
be uh around Amendment
1650 I think repres uh um Amendment
1650 is is adopted into each of the
other amendments 16 the other amendments
do more than what 1650 does but none of
them disagree with 1650 oh I can't even
find um 16 1950 was was the part where
we said we would take the
senior um enrollment component of
499 uh and and pass it there there has
been really no issue by anyone saying no
we shouldn't do that so I I think
1650 is probably an an an easy yes the
the harder conversation is to
um try to come to an agreement within
the finance committee on the tersi
amendment which deals with the summer
EBT program and the whole amendment that
I would summarize if I heard it right to
be let's not take on the summer EBT
program let's put it into a study
committee so I I don't know how you want
to do with that but I I I'd recommend we
discuss 1650
first and and just accept it as an
amendment you are recognized to discuss
it okay okay I I need to find it so
everyone probably should look for
1650 I don't find
it is that that's one of the ones Mr
out you moving
this right now I'm I'm I'm I I I I would
1650 but there's some other amendments
and motions
juggler yeah I kept talking until you
were
thank
you I'm I'm going to keep talking about
1650 for some
context
1650 uh to those who want more than 1650
I I think their argument really is
mostly uh 1650 is necessary but not
sufficient it's not enough of$ 499 to to
to be the bill that they want but I
don't think that there's really any
argument about 1650 this is I think us
all saying that we want to make the
senior uh
enrollment eligibility portion of of of$
499 we want want to make that law the
the reason for that is that currently uh
there's a good deal of paperwork where
seniors have to uh enroll annually uh to
to gain access to uh programs and
benefits that they're entitled to and
what um what this bill will allow for
relatively small investment of
37,500 which would change up the
enrollment processes so that um they
would only need to uh enroll once every
three years and so that would obviously
save our seniors uh time dealing with
paperwork and fighting eligibility
systems it would just make it their
their quality of life better but it'll
also have an A A Manpower impact because
processing fewer applications takes
fewer people so so I think 1650 is a
financially
sound it's
and I don't want to say it's a small
amount of money I'd say it's an amount
of money where I think we're going to re
recoup the investment in a few
years representative
tersi thank you Mr chairman um while I
don't disagree with anything that
representative Edwards just said about
the simplified elderly application I
disagree with his suggestion that we can
pass this one first and move along and
consider other options I think every one
of us have received our inboxes have
been flooded with emails about this bill
and about this amendment right here this
amendment right here is um one that is
simply not in the um the spirit of the
original bill that passed the Senate and
passed the house so um while I do
support the simplified elderly
application it is in my Amendment um
I would be very uncomfortable voting
just for
1650 um because I um have hope that we
can discuss further how we can um expand
more on Senate Bill 499 so so what I'd
be happy to do is withhold moving this
amendment at this point and have the
debate on the other two amendments and
once we have that debate on the other
two amends mend ments this may still
need to be brought forward uh if either
of the other two amendments get passed
this amendment becomes overcome by
events and and is redundant so so so Mr
chair I however you want to proceed on
debating the other two amendments I can
withhold u a motion on 1650 I understand
it's bad politics to tell the public
that we know more about the situation
than they do but that's kind of where
we're at
um I think that's the avoidance part of
1650 Mr chair well if you if you wish
not to bring It Forward then I'll
recognize representa
tersi Mr chair if I may representative H
thank you um I just to bring us back to
where the dock it is the bill came over
from the
Senate the bill was assigned um over to
education but it was vacated and
referred to finance it has not been on
the floor yet in the house um I
apologize you were and so there has been
no policy decisions on this there is a
lot of policy in this this was an
Omnibus Bill that came over from the
Senate with a number of parts we did our
best in in a in a somewhat sprinted
fashion to review
those um but it because there have been
no policy discussions and we're we're
wandering into that policy Arena here at
this point because of the time the the
calendar time I do think it's
appropriate because it hasn't seen a
policy committee that we work on this
but I do think we have to be a little
bit cautious about driving policy at the
last
minute recognize represent thank you I
would like to except my apologies you
are correct I um with the number of
bills division 3 had I mashed up this
one that came to us directly so um but
if I may um if we are going to talk
about um the policy may I discuss my
Amendment Mr chairman you are recognized
thank you um before you is amendment
um first I want to talk about SB 499
which brought us to this point which was
a much larger much more comprehensive
Omnibus Bill that came from the Senate
um an anti-hunger Bill if you will when
we had the public hearing we heard about
five I think it was five different
sections of that bill that addressed a
many different um areas of um um hunger
and they included things like um the
simplified elderly application which we
just heard the summer EBT program then
there was also three different sections
that related specifically to education
division 2 and um were tied into reduced
and free lunch
programming I won't go necessarily into
what happened with that larger bill
because because we had some joint work
sessions we were told it would be
divided up um and then found out that
division two would not be digging into
this bill so with that I will agree um
that
policy my Amendment does not address the
education part of policy I my Amendment
only addresses the sections that relate
to
DHHS so I'll start there that I am
already approaching Senate bill $499 by
removing the three sections that had to
do with um the Department of Education
what you have before you is um an
amendment that is a little unusual in
the way it was drafted because um we
heard some feedback that perhaps members
wanted to see a breakout in costs
whereas the original Bill had one price
tag on it so I'll just jump ahead um if
you look at line 50 that's your elderly
simplified application that is exactly
what representative Edwards just
presented to you about um making it
easier for elderly and disabled persons
to um only have to apply um every few
years that's fine the other part is the
directing the department to implement
the sumary EBT program now for those of
you who may not know what that's about
um for many children who receive free
and reduced lunch during the school year
um they receive two meals a day through
their neighborhood school um when it
comes to Summer Time many of these
children you know are back at home and
families are faced with having to
provide those two meals for the kids on
those 5 days a week that they would have
been in school and received um now that
is um hitting their uh grocery budget
this program is very similar to um the
standard DBT program we probably all
know about which is like a debit card
that you can use on F food only um at
grocery stores that type of thing but
what this does is provide $40 a
month to each child who would qualify
for free and reduced
lunch for the three summer months so
what this really is is
$120 per child to help help and assist
with a family's um grocery budget
because those meals that the child would
have eaten at school are no longer
covered um I just want to look quickly
at a few um data points that we got um
estimates are showing that
37,325 children in our state would
qualify for this program that's a lot of
kids who get their meals at school
during the school year so in the
summertime
their home and it's quite possible that
hard choices had to be made and those
kitchens don't have um the peanut butter
and jelly and the bread that you know
would have been there
otherwise the program um is broken down
in the amendment the Appropriations
excuse me are broken down as I stated
there was some interest in seeing where
the different um line items would go so
you can see that but um the state would
bear 50% of the administrative cost for
this program and the benefits for it are
100% uh federal funds so we are looking
at $4.5 million of federal funds that
will come in and be distributed to the
families in this way um and that money
will be spent locally here in New
Hampshire at our corner corner stores
and our supermarkets um and reinvested
back into the
um the cost for the program in terms of
doing the system updates I know that
that looks to be rather significant the
issue is this without building out the
technology we're always going to be
behind the eightball and not being able
to participate in some kind of program
um there has been some concerns raised
that um if you look at if look at my
Amendment it takes effect July 1
obviously July 1 you have kids that
would qualify in July we don't have the
system up and running so for the 2024
summer and this seems to be a bone of
contention this the DHS would ramp up
and build the program over the summer
and then the families would receive the
funds of the hund and $20 per child by
the time the program got built up I'm
sorry just a 80 because it's July and
August
oh I sure um by the time the systems got
built out it would be the fall and so
they would get that uh benefit in the
fall they estimated maybe October so yes
I understand that it's not actually a
summer program at that point however it
is a supplement for these families that
don't necessarily have the money in the
growth fre budget to help feed these
kids um now building out the system this
summer will allow us to participate
fully for
2025 um if we push it off any further
again you have the ramp up you know you
need to be ready to implement the
program
um I've probably gone on a little too
long I just want you to realize that
this program as drafted in my Amendment
is significantly less than what the
original bill was this is really just
two parts um that DHHS is
um willing to implement it has the way
that my amendment was drafted actually
brought the total cost down from the
original fiscal note uh by a little bit
so I appreciate that I hope that you can
consider this we have kids in this state
that are hungry
um there are I know that people will say
that there's other programs there are
but we need to make sure that none of
these kids slip through the cracks these
are these are kids who through no choice
of their own um are in a household that
perhaps can't afford to get food um in
their kitchens during the summer months
and I please ask that you consider my
Amendment thank you for giving me so
much time I appreciate
it may I comment there Edward uh uh
thank you Mr chair um the the department
had contacted me after the division vote
saying that this was a really high
priority for them they uh they
entertained me for an hour uh on two
separate days to go over
details the one of the biggest details
we went into was exactly what the money
would buy and what we found in general
was that the the money spent would help
some in 2024 and really pay off in 20 25
and that there were a lot of different
things that needed to be invested in and
so when we had initially just taken a
look at a a single total dollar amount
uh it it just it struck me that there
was uncertainty about what that money
was really going to pay for and so
that's why you see sort of an unusual
breakout in the appropriation because
representative tersi was open to that
and in her Amendment and and I I think
that was for visibility and transparency
and intended to breed some confidence in
the in the in the uh committee should
they want to pass this that this was a
legit serious uh budgeting effort to to
forecast the costs so I'm I'm not I'm
not advocating for or against the tersi
amendment I just did want to explain
that there was a lot of extra work
outside of the committee and and that
this Amendment reflects the the the
input of the department representative
tersi and I think a lot of people trying
to figure out what the money would be
going for so thank thank
you representative hle thank you Mr
chair um thank you representative Tori
for bringing this forward it does in
fact reduce the costs a little bit um
not withstanding my concern about the
fact that our federal deficit is growing
and is now north of $103,000 per person
and I can't guarantee that we're going
to continue to be able to receive money
from the federal government I do think
as an engineer um the costs associated
with lines 31 through on page one
through lines three on page two is
excessive
and that is the part of the reason I
drafted an amendment 1957 H I would love
to see a plan from our from the
Department of DHHS that shows how we're
we're going to roll this out have the
rfps in place have some preliminary
language necessary to do this such that
this could be filed in next legislative
season I do understand that that
does that does create the potential cost
loss of this year's funding for for
those that are impacted but I also think
having a plan that might in fact reduce
that number down significantly maybe
north of 4 or 500,000
even better leverages what we spend in
in the state relative to what we receive
from the federal government so um I know
there's three amendments here um I do
think there is some Appropriations in
the amendment 1917 H that are excessive
and I think it behooves us to look at
the third amendment I I agree with you
that you know that it seems to me that
all these people that are covered by
this program are already covered by
another program they should be getting
food stamps they should be getting snap
and so why are we so worried that
they're not covered and this is perhaps
double spending and redundant spending
and and if you have a study maybe that
will discover one one way or the other
if there's anybody overlooked so I would
support your Amendment if you want to
bring that forward sure Mr chair I would
like to move Amendment um 2024 1957 H
by
second
second representative Mooney motion
before us is to adopt Amendment 1957
H further discussion may I speak to the
amendment yes thank you so um lines 1
through 19 are effectively the same as
what was adopted in Prior amendments
relative to the elderly section of the
snap program so there's no changes there
the changes start with line 20 and run
through 31 and what this does is to
allow for us to facilitate working with
the federal government for this EBT
program but to start the to getting the
department ready to adopt these plans by
putting together a project plan putting
together the necessary
rfps and getting in and the the
quotations relative to getting this done
but not actually implementing this until
a subsequent Bill happens and I think
the $50,000 which was a number pulled
out of the air a little bit is more than
sufficient for them to cover the cost to
put together a project plan for of this
size so I would ask that you would
support
it represent
stringle uh thank you Mr
chair um uh I'd like to challenge the
assumptions that come with this
amendment that by um reducing uh the
appropriation of 667,000 with this bill
and replacing it with a
$50,000 uh study uh that that uh uh were
only losing the October payments um that
these uh students would be eligible for
these children would be eligible for
because um basically by the time this
project plan is complet uh completed
will be in the next uh next bium uh we
file a bill uh in January it comes out
uh the uh we have a project plan it's
not going to be able to be implemented
by the summer of 2025 we're going to be
either either uh um uh Distributing
these cards in the fall of 2025 late or
we'll maybe all the way to the summer of
2026 so uh the the question is and if if
if you know this is indeed a worth a
worthwhile plan and I know understand
that uh some have concerns about the
necessity because of other uh uh food
programs that are available for these
people um this does nothing to address
address that question uh to have a
project plan and a $50,000
appropriation um uh I think in the
process of implementing this uh uh each
one of these sections the the the uh
department is going to follow their
their good purchasing processes uh and
um uh and we'll we'll get the value out
of the the money that's appropriated to
implement this program uh so I would uh
strongly uh urge us to turn this
amendment down and go back to the tersi
amendment which is still a very very
scaled down compromised version of what
came over from the Senate thank you
thank you representative walner thank
you I just want to remind the committee
that by not moving forward with this at
this point what we're doing is denying
about $4.5 million do a year for the
next year to some of the lowest income
families in this
state yes the kids are home in the
summer and they need to be fed because
they don't have SCH school lunch but I
can tell you that those kids also need F
meals in October November December
January they need additional funds these
families are living on such limited
budgets our food stamps or SNAP program
does not provide them with what they
need to really nourish their families
and I really think that everyone needs
to walk out of here today thinking about
that we have just denied the lowest
income families in this state these
additional
benefits further discussion
representative tersi thank you very much
I just want
to dispel one myth that these are
families that are already receiving the
benefits if you think about it this way
say you have a family that receives the
monthly SNAP
benefit and their children go to school
their child goes to school
and they're getting two meals a day at
school that the family does not have to
pay for because they qualify for that
program so their snap monthly benefit
pays for all the other meals that they
have in that household including the
dinner for the child now let's go to
Summertime the child is not receiving
those meals because they are not in
school and that same monthly benefit
that the family receives has to now pay
for 10 more meals for that child for
that breakfast and lunch that that child
is no longer
receiving so I just wanted to make that
clear um
I have some thoughts about um
representative H's Amendment how he
basically said he made up the number of
$50,000 as being enough um I just I
don't think it's worth kicking the can
down the road kicking the can down the
road um we have
children right now in this state that
can benefit from this yes it is a
investment in state funds to get there
but once we invest in this program to
set it up then we have over 37,000 kids
that are going to get meals and I please
encourage you to come back to my
amendment to see how we can implement it
as soon as possible thank you it is my
belief that those 10 meals they get a
week in school are all Al already paid
for under snap and food stamps so
they're double dipping if you will so
that's what I've always believed further
discussion representative Heath thank
you Mr
chair we've just come through a pandemic
people rents are out of
control
um we we know that our senior citizens
are a population that are in
need I I this bill came out of the
Senate with I believe a 25 to zero
vote I have to say if I we walk out of
here today without passing at least the
tersi me uh amendment I will be
ashamed we are better than this we need
to do something this is a tough time for
a lot me New Hampshire is a wealthy
State luckily our revenues are still
coming in at a pretty good Pace not as
good as they were but we have some
obligations to our poorest children
families and adults we need to do
something I just think we we need to go
with at least the turoski amendment we
can't put this off anymore it's not
right it's not fair thank
chair so I look at this at a much a
broader
perspective this is yet another welfare
program and it goes
back to the 60s in the Great Society
program that President Johnson
passed and that program was passed with
the strong support of the late former
Senator Daniel Patrick Monahan who was a
stalwart of the Democrat Party and a big
supporter of the great the Great Society
program when it was
passed decades later and he was a
researcher um when he did
research what he found was these welfare
programs are not working they only serve
to keep people in poverty they have not
helped to bring them out of poverty and
here we have another Federal program in
the case of New Hampshire 5 million doll
for summer food on top of all the other
welfare programs that we have for food
and other aspects of
life
and as we've heard others say the
federal government's broke so the fact
that we're taking more money from them
to continue to impoverish people just
does not make sense I oppose this from
the get-go um I'm I am supportive of
Representative Hall's amendment to look
into whether the this is something that
can be um implemented but I don't think
it makes sense to continue to take
federal dollars um at infan item as
we've been doing especially over the
last TW four years since 2020 thank
you further discussion representative
hle thank you Mr chair
um yesterday you handed out a sheet of
paper from the LBA showing what we had
for bills that were house bills not
including Senate bills and the total
Appropriations at this time was 152
million right with general fund having
potentially um 62 million available or
something so we're going to have to make
some tough choices in the next six weeks
before session ends and I think it's
time to start making some of those tough
choices and one way to make that tough
choice is to allow this conceptual
planning to go forward but not
necessarily start the program if you
start the program we are actually
spending not the
$667,000 that was just talked about but
it's a little over a million dollars on
this one program and I don't think that
funding is coming out of anything else
and I haven't seen a detailed sheet from
the Department showing why the costs are
so high when we've seen from the IT
department on other programs the
implementation costs are closer to
$100,000 not over
600,000 thank you are we ready for the
vote representative groden thank you I
want to make an observation
in
that I've heard that I
believe that food stamps and snap
programs take care of this and that this
is double dipping and I see some nods
like this and I see some nods like this
and this committee should know that you
should have those facts and you should
have that
data and I'm disappointed that you don't
Point representative papichi Muller
we're beating this to death by the I
agree that we should have that data the
burden to provide the data to support
the bill is with the people who advocate
for the bill we've done the best we
could we've asked for additional data
this is all the data we got so that's
the data we are working
with representative
Lane thank you um I would Echo what uh
repres representative Grody said and I
guess in recognition of the fact that
welfare does not solve poverty my
thought is until we find a way to do it
we shouldn't cut out those who are most
in need and if we need a new solution
then let's come up with it but leaving
money on the table for those for the
children is just to me inexcusable and
like representative Heath said I'm only
a substitute but I'm going to have to go
explain this to people and I'm going to
be it's going to be hard thank
you are we ready for the vote cler we'll
call the we show what are we voting on
show show of hands on the whole
Amendment 1957 excuse me Mr chairman if
I may point of privilege why does that
Amendment bubble to the top here because
it you you you discussed an amendment
but you did not make a
motion he made the motion that's why it
moves
forward Mr chair we had open them all
for
discussion if I may let's take a vote on
I I I think in all fairness let's take a
vote on Tori's Amendment she talked
about it first even if there was not a
motion please make a motion to for the
purpose of adoption and then we can take
a vote on it that I'm okay with that all
right withdra we'll do a show of hands
on the tersi amendment 1
1917 all in favor please raise your
hands sorry Mr chair don't you need a
motion I never made the motion and there
was no second please make the motion I
would like to move amendment 20241
917h to Senate Bill 499 thank you second
it okay are we ready now all in favor
hands question do I 13 must I vote I
didn't I didn't he didn't vote he didn't
vote I vote and committee vote Yes yes I
I'm
AR FSE
13 Mr chair I move amendment number
whatever the number was
1957 yes thank
you all right is there a second second
second by
Earth further discussion seeing none
raise your hands if you support
opposed
12 repres I recognize repr a whole for
motion Mr chair I move that we pass
Senate Bill 499 with Amendment 1957
H further discussion seeing none clerk
will call a roll on the motion ought to
r o to pass as amended
by Amendment 1957 on Senate Bill
499 representative uh thank you Mr chair
representative Earth yes representative
Maguire representative Petri votes yes
representative Emer yes representative
Griffin yes representative Mooney yes
representative Edwards yes
representative Bean yes representative
hle yes representative Sweeney yes
representative camell yes representative
papichi Muller yes Representative walner
no representative Grody no
representative Buco uh no representative
line no representative Heath no shame on
US Representative Shapiro
no representative evil no representative
Tori no representative haken Phillips no
representative Stringham nope
representative grassy no representative
Priest No representative wer yes Mr
chairman the vote is 13 to 12 in favor
of the
motion motion is
adopted moving on to Senate Bill 56
there will be a Minority Report sir who
will write it me you're a busy writer I
am and it'll be ought to pass with my
and representative Hull will write the
majority report absolutely
17 representative Edwards uh thank you
Mr chair
um the next two uh are Party Line issues
um as well I I hope we can maintain
dequorum as we get through this it's
late in the day uh s SP 56 7 uh
directing the department of HHS to
compile a report on the availability of
uh MF prone and Mesa
proall um the uh committee met and
recommended itl uh 54 um on a Partyline
vote and I would turn it over to
representative
Mooney thank you Mr chair I would move
567 second motion on a second itl Senate
Bill 567 further discussion seeing none
you're ready for
the represent hacken Phillips I'm happy
to defer to representative to she had
her hanging up before
me thank
you
um abortions are an important and legal
component of our reproductive Healthcare
here in New Hampshire and mytha prone
and missa prol are prescribed by
Healthcare Providers through 11 weeks
for safe medical abortions they've been
using the medication for years decades
even access to appropriate health care
and in particular to reproductive Health
Care does vary throughout the
state and while we recognize that the
Department of Health and Human Services
could compile this report without the
legislation We Believe believe that this
issue is an important policy area in
which the legislature should give
specific Direction about an initiative
that could inform both DHHS and the
legislature about any changes that need
to be made to ensure access to this
important reproductive Health Care
Drug and the fiscal impact we were told
is exceedingly minimal so I will be
voting against the itl motion and I urge
my colleagues to join me thank you is
only about a report remember comment
representative um I I I just want to
make it clear that the division 3 vote
to say itl had nothing to do with
abortion I'll say it again because it's
going to get misrepresented in the media
and once we leave the room our vote had
nothing to do with abortion what we have
as facts before us is that the law
around uh whether or not the FDA had
used the prop procedures to approve
these two particular drugs uh are have
been adjudicated by a Texas Federal
court and then reviewed by uh an appell
at court and uh it went to an appeals
court uh and neither of those two courts
had any conflict in the their opinion
that these drugs did not go through the
standard FDA practices for safety and
efficacy the the the rules around safety
and efficacy were violated Texas thought
that the violation was so severe that
they wanted to do an injunction against
having the two drugs the uh Circuit
Court agreed that the that the drugs had
not gone through an a proper approval U
but disagreed that an injunct an
injunction was appropriate neither Court
disputed that the FDA violated their
safety efficacy uh clinical research
protocols not a not an issue this went
to the Supreme Court it's in the Supreme
Court still um where the Supreme Court
is determining whether or not the
injunction and the relief from the re
injunction was good law they're they're
as I understand it they're not even
reviewing the the fact that um the the
the FDA approval process was uh
circumvented to to uh get these to
Market Center so it's not settled law
it's still in the Supreme Court so it's
premature I think for New Hampshire to
step out in front of something that is
going to be settled probably in a few
months we don't know when it's going to
be settled but it's not going to be a
year because the Supreme Court's already
uh taken testimony on it so so it's not
settled law also the the comment was
made that the department could do this
without
legislation the department could do a
lot of things without legis islation but
they have no Charter to do this sort of
thing they have no history no precedent
no experience no existing reports that
cause them to go in and take a look at
uh the availability of of a particular
by name uh prescription and determine if
there are barriers to access and and the
like so we would this law is necessary
to compel DHHS to do an unn an unnatural
act that it's never done before it's not
in their mission so um so there's that
um but uh there there there is this it
happens to be passionate because in the
background is the whole abortion debate
but from a legislative perspective from
what New Hampshire ought to be doing we
ought not to be trying to supplement
multi-billion doll marketing budgets of
the pharmaceutical companies we don't do
this for any other drug
there are currently because of the China
supply chain issues there are a number
of prescription drugs that are having
accessib problems we're not asking to go
research those drugs to make sure that
they're more available so I I I I don't
think that we need to be getting into
the micromanagement of this and I I
strongly think that itl was the proper
motion representative hacken
Phillips thank you Mr chair for
recognizing me um so I'm trying to stay
as calm as possible I am a co-sponsor on
this bill and
um I just so happen to be one of the 50%
of the state in voters who believe this
issue is of critical importance in fact
the number one issue in my voting
district so to hear folks say that um
that this bill that could have an effect
in our state is not um you know worthy
of discussion today or passage into law
um I think that's severely misguided
from the actual um way our voters feel
let me start by saying that the federal
court cases that are you know working
through the system right now will take
take place and they will they will come
out we will find out what they think um
but for us to relitigate that FDA
concern here um is inappropriate because
that this bill is not talking about that
um the FDA process is not what this bill
is about what this bill would do for our
state would to be studying the increased
access and challenges to that access to
these two
drugs so when I think of those 50% of
Voters across the state who are
affected by whether or not they can
receive these drugs the challenges that
are presented to them and their
providers when trying to get access to
those
drugs I know it affects our estate and
that we should be studying it because of
the fact that there's an ongoing OBGYN
shortage in our
state and this particular bill is
relevant to that because these two drugs
are part of the toolbox that this
profession uses to address Health Care
access and procedures in our state that
affects 50% of the people in our state
so I'm not sure if everyone's aware here
but last week the American Medical
Association produced a journal article
that
tracks states that have enacted bans yes
bans including those States like ours
that has a 24-week abortion ban with
limited exceptions so that was within
the prview of the study the study showed
that in states that have enacted this
legislation that they're having trouble
recruiting and retaining OBGYN residents
in their programs across the
country that
creating healthc care delivery problems
it's also creating a shortage of future
OBGYNs uh yes this bill is of critical
importance for the future of not only
Women's Healthcare but of the health
care of their family members as well and
the way that their families can function
and the way they can contribute to
society and our economy in particular
which I know is relevant to this
committee's
work I do not believe the motion is
appropriate at this time for those exact
reasons and I hope that this membership
on this committee will be able to see
beyond the larger culture War before The
Supreme Court um and you know working
through our court systems and focus on
what's Happening Here in our
state be concerned about the access
issues and the challenges to those
access and to also I'm so sorry I'm very
close to finishing chair wer if you
could just let me wrap that up um so I I
would say that you
know to dismiss this is not relevant to
our state I think is a major error I
think that it is relevant I think that
the study will be important that the
reporting mechanisms built into the law
will be important for the future of
healthc care in our state thank you you
Mr repetition that's
all representative Edwards make it short
yes yes sir I think the video will show
I never used the word irrelevant so that
didn't come from me uh I said that uh
this is premature because the body of
law is not settled I said that this is
something the department never does
hasn't been in their mission and uh and
that the selection of these two drugs is
the initiation of a culture war that
wasn't necessary and to have a response
to it is is of course there's going to
be a response if there's an initiative
and and the implication of of the prior
comments is that we have women who can't
get these two drugs there's nothing that
interferes with uh uh physicians in New
Hampshire prescribing these uh they
we're not getting in between we're not
stopping we're not hindering these the
availability of these two drugs uh as a
legislature and so to pretend as though
you know access is somehow constrained
and restricted I I that's a dystopian
View that just doesn't seem to exist in
in New Hampshire these drugs are not
being withheld they are available
through normal physician patient
relationships so that I I itl is the
right recommendation sir cler will
caller roll on the motion of inexpedient
567 thank you Mr
chairman representative Earth yes
represent McGuire yes representative
Petri votes yes representative Emer yes
representative Griffin yes
representative Mooney yes representative
Edwards yes representative Bean yes
representative hle yes representative
Sweeny yes represent camroll yes
representa papichi Muller yes
Representative
walner no representative Grody no
representative buo no Representative
lanee no representative Heath no
representative Shapiro no representative
Vel no Representative tki
no representative haen Phillips no
representative Stringham no
representative grassy no representative
Priest No representative wer yes Mr
chair the motion passes 13 to 12
motion is adopted representative Edwards
for Senate Bill
596 there will be a Minority Report on
the previous Bill sir who will be the
author uh me okay we got a lot of work
to do okay and and so you should have me
down as um majority report majority
report yes sir all right okay so um last
but not least SB
596 um this is relative to definition of
disability or special needs under the
child care
scholarship um I have an amendment that
was uh shown to division 3 earlier today
um to be fair to the process there
hadn't been a lot of time to to discuss
it um essentially what the underlying
bill is attempting to well I'll I'll
just leave it at that I I I could make a
motion to adopt um
Amendment
2024 1933 H to SB 596 second Motion in a
second to adopt 1 19338 representative
Edwards is recognized to explain it uh
thank you uh the underlying Bill
596 um basically
untethers the U the discovery of
children who who may have in the future
um propensity to having special needs or
or at risk for it so the objective is a
good one let's let's try to
identify kids as early as possible and
because we think it's a good idea to try
to do that we'd like to make sure that
we do it well and do it right and so so
rather than un what what what the
underlying Bill does it tethers us from
any legal definition of the new category
of eligib ability and instead refers to
uh uh care assessment plans that would
be um uh used to test kids uh and those
assessment plans which have not been
picked or Chosen and that the
legislature has no clue which ones they
are what the selection criteria for them
would be uh would be determinative on
whether or not um a a a kid was
identified as as having a a current or
Future Special Needs problem um and if
they do have a special needs problem
then they become eligible for an extra
$100 a month or so uh to help with um
child care expenses there's nothing in
the bill currently to say what a child
care provider should do in exchange for
the additional money that they would get
the benefit of the bill the interest
behind the bill seems to be let's just
get our child care people more money and
this is a good way to do it well it's I
I understand the temptation to just get
more money to child care providers but
there are too many uncertain questions
here we don't know uh uh which tests
might be used and which ones wouldn't be
appropriate we don't know which
community of evaluators should be used
in order to uh conduct these assessments
um in the bill itself s it just says
they need to be licensed professionals
but licensed professionals at what uh
this is really these kind of assessments
are critical and so uh you wouldn't even
want a bachelor's person do it I think
you'd want a master's level person do it
the Bill's silent on that um so uh also
once these kids get identified there
really ought to be a way to make sure
that they get some Services immediately
for the extra money that would be
invested in them but but as
significantly and maybe more importantly
is that there ought to be some concept
of how th that identification would feed
into um integrated services like
Medicaid and public schools so so what
this proposal does is essentially
says look great idea we're not
disagreeing with the objective but let's
please let's just get it right let's get
a study committee together and have the
uh study committee um study the
definition of disability or special
needs under the child scholarship
program study the standardized and
approved Early Childhood developmental
screening tools necessary to determine
the eligibility study the verification
process for the results of the screening
tool used to determine
eligibility the bill is silent on all of
those determine the size of the
population served by the program
identify how incremental changes to the
program including changes to the
definition of disability or special
needs may affect its scope and project
and project Associated costs in state
and federal funding sources so so lines
25 through 27 basically say come on we
need to do a good financial analysis of
this and that hasn't been done yet um uh
line 28 picks up with the the section
five study any other issues identified
through the legislative hearings on 596
including but not necessarily limited to
uh the minimum performance standards and
metrics to be achieved in exchange for
receipt of additional funds made
available by the program uh issues
associated with integrating this program
with Medicaid or public school service
transitions so I that's good committee
work that would make a really great Bill
if we knew what we were doing and
currently 596 doesn't have the
legislature in informed about what it is
we would be asking the department to do
I think we need to slow down and do our
homework and the study committee does
that so it's got the regular represent
representations of the legislature and
then it invites the committee to invite
a design of uh the DHHS commissioner the
design of the Department of Education uh
commissioner child care
provider provided as appointed by the
child care advocacy Council a rep of the
Community Mental Health Center that
works with young children a represent a
representative from the early supports
and Services Program by is supported by
the Community Support Network public uh
school preschool programs representative
from Head Start that's all coordination
and communication and integration that
should precede the legislation and
hasn't yet representative Edwards moves
Amendment 1 1933 is there a second
second further discussion ready for the
question no representative wer
representative
walner thank you so I I'd just like to
move back to square one for a minute
what what was the what is the intent of
the bill and who does it who is it t
targeted
at
so often there are children we're talk
we're talking about very young children
children under the age of
five one two I look around the room I
imagine everybody has spent time in
their life with a one or a two or a
three-year-old um sometimes those
children are not developing
at the regular rate and they may have
behaviors particularly that make it kind
of difficult for them to be in a
group and what this bill is looking
at is finding a way of doing an early
assessment and these are done all the
time the department would decide which
instrument would be used which of the um
instruments would be used and through
this
assessment it would help them integrate
into a child care center many of these
children actually end up finding the par
parents find those children expelled
from child care because their ha
behavior is such that the providers
cannot meet their
needs they often cannot get into child
care for the same reasons the the
provider feels they can't meet their
needs this gives the provider a little
bit of Revenue to help the provider try
to address those needs and most of it's
around being able to have some
additional
Staffing so you know the additional
person to sit at in circle time so that
this little person isn't touching
everybody and running around the
room going on field trips so that this
child can be also included in going on
field
trips sitting down and reading a story
with a child one on-one these are kids
who need a lot of often need a lot of
one-on-one attention and this would just
help provide some
additional U financing to help the
centers and the child care providers
have that the the division of Health and
Human Services already runs a program
this program it's already in place this
just includes a new group of children in
that program um the cost is actually
very very low I don't even I can't
remember what it is they've spent to
date uh but I don't believe they're even
spending in this program what they had
scheduled to spend um in the last
budget so this is just really enabling
those children to be able to attend
child care and get the kind of extra
help they need and a little bit of a
little bit of extra help when you're 2
three 4 is going to go a long way
towards getting you ready for school so
that you can be successful in
school so I hope that the committee will
take a look at this and not not develop
another committee I can tell you there
are so many Child Care committees and
many of them have already done the work
here the department knows how to run
this program they know how to pick an
instrument to do the
assessments um everything is already in
place to do this this is not Reinventing
the wheel this is all there we just need
to have some resources to help these
children be able to integrate into child
care and I also want to remind you that
these if these kids cannot be in child
care that probably means their parent is
not working and I would think that would
be something this committee would be
very concerned about um if children are
not being able to be cared for in child
care and parents are unable to work so
I'm you know glad that I would you
allowed me to tell you what the real
story was I I protest I I did tell a
real story I I don't like the
implication that what I said wasn't
truthful you may disagree with it but it
was truthful and
real all those in favor of adopting
Amendment
12 recognize representative hold for a
motion
Mr chair I move um Senate Bill 596 with
the adoption of amendment 2024 1933
H second Motion in a second to adopt 596
ought to pass as amended with Amendment
1933 clerk will call a rooll on that
motion thank you Mr
chairman representative F yes
representative Maguire yes represent
Petri votes yes representative Emer yes
representative Griffin yes
representative Mooney yes representative
Edwards yes representative Bean yes
representative
hle
yes representative Sweeny yes
representative camell yes representative
papichi Muller
yes representative Gro uh
walner
no represent Grody no
representative Buco no representative
Lane no representative Heath no
representative Shapiro no representative
evil no Representative tki no
representative haen Phillips no
representative Stringham no
representative grassy no representative
Priest No representative
wer yes Mr chair of the V is 13 to 12 in
favor of the
adopted all right representative who's
going to write the minority is there a
Minority Report and who will write it
okay all right so I'll be looking
tomorrow for all these reports when you
send them to me an email also send them
to Janet so that I won't have to double
it up and if you have your if you filled
out the forms I distributed yesterday
I'll take those today or whenever you
get them done uh so I'll be looking at
those as well we don't have any meeting
tomorrow so I'll be looking at all these
reports I think there's about 20 of them
do some of them
are many
many
so I just want to clarify you did say by
tomorrow though right thank thank you
that is appreciated I know you've added
on some that you didn't have a chance to
write and I appreciate you doing that so
and and I don't have a chance to read
them all today anyway so I'll be looking
for them tomorrow as we'll Janet because
we're coming up on a deadline so the
earlier the
better
so but I know we'll be able to get him
into the afternoon I appreciate all of
you being here today and I appreciate
the replacements that came thank you all
for your good work and for your staying
here
late we are
adjourned Democrats all um maybe meet in